Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss.
Oh Leute, ist schon ein paar Tage her, wo ich zuletzt on war. Wo war ich denn zuletzt on?
Ich muss mal kurz selber gucken. Ich war am Dienstag, kann das sein?
Da steht ja leider vor 5 Tagen und sowas, da sieht man nicht genau, das ist das genaue Datum.
Muss mal kurz in mein Creator Dashboard gucken. Da müsste das stehen.
Zeig mal her, Statistik.
Das müsste am Dienstag gewesen sein. Ja genau, Dienstag, 4. Januar.
Der ist schon ein bisschen her.
So, gut, nachdem wir uns das angeguckt haben, muss ich jetzt mal warten, bis Twitch gecheckt hat, dass der Stream richtig on ist.
Ah, jetzt kommen die ersten Leute. Okay, jetzt hat es Twitch wahrscheinlich gecheckt.
Weil ansonsten wäre das not stonks gewesen.
Ich habe letztens irgendwo gelesen, ich glaube auf Reddit, wobei ich das nicht so ganz nachvollziehen kann.
Aber es hat zumindest ein ehemaliger Amazon-Twitch-Mitarbeiter geschrieben.
Da ging es darum, dass der Anteil, dieser 50-50-Anteil auch für Prime-Subs doch geändert werden soll. Was er ja nicht wird, aber viele wollen, dass er das wird.
Und der hat geschrieben, dass große Streamer, so um 5.000, oder um 3.000, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, ja in den 1.000 dann auf jeden Fall, und mehr,
obwohl Twitch gar nicht so viel Geld bringen würden, weil sie mehr kosten, als dass sie sich ihre Nicht-Prime-Subs bezahlen.
Wobei ich da meine Zweifel habe, ob das stimmt. Letztendlich sind das die Aushängeschilder, die die Leute auf die Plattform bringen.
Und wenn sie nicht direkt Geld machen sollten, dann auf jeden Fall ziemlich viel indirekt.
So, und angeblich würden mittlere Streamer so ab 100 Zuschauern, also dazu zähle ich ja auch, ich habe ja so 100 bis 400, je nachdem.
Normalerweise habe ich irgendwas so um 250, 300 oder so, dazu hat er nichts gesagt, deswegen weiß man das nicht so genau.
Und die würden angeblich die Seite bezahlen, weil die meistens mehr Subs als Zuschauer haben.
Also okay, das klingt irgendwie nachvollziehbar, aber so richtig logisch erscheint es mir aber trotzdem nicht.
Ja, und Kleine schaffen es gerade mal, sich selbst zu finanzieren. Na gut, was auch immer.
Ich habe da meine Zweifel, dass das stimmt. Joho, danke für den Sub, 6 Monate, du hast jetzt glaube ich den Silberkeks, oder?
Ja, wann gibt es den Silberkeks? Ab 3 Monate, ab 3 Monate. Den Diamantkeks gibt es jetzt, genau, um 6 Monate gibt es den.
Du musst von den Prime Subs, ja, man muss von allen Subs was abgeben.
Aber Jeff kassiert nicht wirklich doppelt, man kann Prime Subs eigentlich sehen als, Jeff bezahlt mich mit was, was er schon hatte.
Also im Endeffekt habt ihr alle Prime bezahlt und davon kriege ich was ab, wenn man es so will.
Und wahrscheinlich mehr insgesamt als die an Prime verdienen, vermute ich jetzt mal. Ich weiß es aber nicht, genau.
Also er überweist mir Jeff was bei einem Prime Sub. Ihr bezahlt Jeff zuerst und Jeff gibt mir ein bisschen was davon ab.
Ich glaube so kann man Prime Subs sehen.
Ah, yes.
So.
Kann man mehrere Accounts Prime Subs haben wenn man das braucht? Oh, das weiß ich nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Wie oft bezahlt man denn Prime, wenn man Prime Family benutzt?
Einmal und dann beliebe ich viele Accounts.
Okay, Twitch Account muss, einmal geht das wohl nur. Weil Twitch Accounts need to be linked to Primary Amazon Account.
Wir haben 69 Zuschauer Leute. Anscheinend geht das nicht. Ach ja, jetzt wo ich hier gerade in meiner Browser Historie sehe, wollen wir mal gucken was New World so macht.
Die waren unter 100.000 Spieler letztens.
Okay Leute, ich hab Mist erzählt. Sie waren nicht unter 100.000. Sie waren bei 100.863. Sie waren nicht unter 100.000.
Da würde jetzt so ein richtiger Hardcore New World Fanboy voll drauf abgehen so nach dem Motto.
Leute, glaubt ihr Max nicht. Der hat gesagt, New World ist unter 100.000 Zuschauer. Das stimmt nicht. Das könnt ihr bei SteamStats nachgucken.
Dann guckst du halt nach und am Ende sind es 100.863.
Ja, also ich hätte vermutet, die waren unter 100.000, aber die waren ganz knapp über 100.000 noch. Aber es ist wieder, hier, all time low.
Guck mal, heute haben wir sogar 100.072.
Also mal Battlefield. Battlefield war unter 10.000 letztens.
Ah, super. Das korrigiert die Dinger teilweise nachträglich noch ein bisschen, weil ich hab letztens geguckt, da waren sie bei 9.000. Vor zwei Tagen oder so erst.
Fake News, genau.
Das ist so RIP. So im Arsch. Aber das ist halt beispiellos. Ich habe noch nie.
Also mir fällt, glaub ich, nichts anderes ein, was in diesen Sphären war und so schnell so krass getroppt ist wie New World.
Es gibt jede Menge Failspiele von Fallout 76 bis Wolcen bis sonst was.
Die hatten auch alle viele Spiele, aber nicht so viel, aber von einer Million zu droppen auf unter 100.000.
Na gut, sagen wir mal von 900.000 auf 100.000 zu droppen in zwei Monaten oder so. Das ist halt schon richtig heftig.
Jetzt musst du das mal schaffen. Aber die haben sich auch redlich verdient bei Amazon.
Die haben ja auch alle Register gezogen, von irgendwelchen Kleinzeit-Hit-Detections bis drooping Bugs und ohne Ende.
Ja, Hardline.
Ja, ich weiß, dass es immer den Maximalwert zeigt, aber ich hatte diese Woche vor ein paar Tagen geguckt.
Da waren sowohl, nee Schwachsinn stimmt nicht, da war New World unter 100.000 und Battlefield war unter 10.000, aber nicht für den Tag.
Egal, letztendlich die paar 100 Spieler machen es jetzt auch nicht fett.
Ja, das ist witzig. Als ich das im Video gesagt habe, Leute, das muss ich euch zeigen.
Das Comment muss ich euch zeigen, da lacht ihr euch kaputt.
Der Typ ist so geil.
Loll, auf Steam hat Blablabla mehr als Blablabla, während 80% über Origin laufen. Allein der Fakt ist eigentlich genug, um dich zu debanken.
Das Spiel ist schon seltsam. Er hat mich debankt, Alter. Im Sparbuch hat er mich debankt.
Ganz davon abgesehen, selbst wenn ich das jetzt nicht so lustig finde, dass er mich debankt hätte.
Es ist genau das, was ich im Video sage. Ich sag glaube ich innerhalb der ersten zwei Minuten, die Spielerzahlen auf Steam sind natürlich nicht alles.
Konsolen und Origin sind da ja nicht drin, aber der Trend wird ähnlich sein, wenn nicht genauso, aber ähnlich.
Das sage ich fast wortwörtlich im Video.
Und anscheinend hat es Excruciate, das ist auch ziemlich falsch geschrieben, falls er das meint, was ich denke, dass er meint.
Da hat er mich halt debankt, richtig hart hat die Bunker. Sollte zu den Mistbusters.
Ne du, Dankeschön für sechs Monate. Du hast jetzt den Diamantkeks. Poggers. Dankeschön für den Massive.
Direkt vorher pausiert er erstmal. Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich. Dabei sage ich das mehr oder weniger im gleichen Satz.
Naja. So sind sie halt.
Summa Aufmerksamkeitsspanne. Da machst du nichts.
Da sind E. Leute, hier sind teilweise die geilsten Comments dabei.
Egal, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an. Ich habe gesehen, der Fabian Siegelsborn hat auch ein Video dazu gemacht.
Und dort sind witzigerweise die Comments teilweise genauso dumm.
Das macht eigentlich auch keinen Unterschied. Ich finde das lustig.
Du hast da teilweise, du hast da echt teilweise die gleichen Hardcore-Fanboys.
Oder Leute, die noch nicht mal irgendwie Hardcore-Fanboys sind, aber irgendwie die einfachste Sätze nicht verstehen.
Aber das ist ja auf YouTube nichts besonderes. Leute, die normale Sätze nicht verstehen.
Sag mal, welchen Router benutzt du noch gleich? Ich benutze einen Hex PoE.
Inner. Geht zwar 50 Euro irgendwo bei Amazon. Nee, nee, nee, nicht 80. Lul, Alter. Ja, so was hier in dem Dreh. 50.
Das da habe ich. Sieht scheiße aus, ist aber gut.
Wenn man die Zusatzfunktion braucht, wenn man ein einfaches Web-UI will, was man auch als Noob bedienen kann,
dann ist das Mikrotik-Router-OS vielleicht nicht das Beste.
Vorne die WLAN-Einrichtung. Ich weiß, hier hat mir jemand von euch mal WLANs über Router-OS eingerichtet.
Ist schon ziemlich der Abfahrt. Und ich frage mich, warum ihr das nicht einfacher machen könnt.
Hängt der hinter der Fritzbox oder am DSD? Der hängt hinter der Fritzbox.
Ich habe letztens, wenn das, wenn das, wer auch Frage hat, wieder mein Netzwerk aufgebaut.
Ich habe irgendwo hier ein Video gemacht letztens, wo ich das gezeigt habe, wie das bei mir lokal aufgebaut ist.
Vorne hängt die Fritzbox. Die macht auch noch ein bisschen mehr. Die macht noch Deckt und sowas.
Genau, hier male ich es noch dran. Das ist Internet an der Fritzbox.
Das ist kein DSL-Modem, das ist Vodafone, Kabelstells. Und dahinter ist der Router.
Das habe ich allein schon aus dem Grund, weil ich nicht will, dass Unity Media
Zugriff hat auf meine internen Geräte, weil die können sich ja auf dem Provider-Router einloggen.
Ja, das ist wirklich zu empfehlen. Ich sehe das auch nicht ein, dass ich meine
internen Geräte direkt an Provider-Router stecken soll. Keine zusätzliche.
Der eine Hopp mehr macht es wirklich jetzt nicht fett.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, als bist du von einem Ping unter einer Millisekunde auf einmal auf 15
Millisekunden rauf, nur weil du einen Router dazwischen steckst. Du bist wahrscheinlich von
einer halben Millisekunde auf 0,6 Millisekunden rauf oder so, wenn überhaupt.
Das geht eigentlich noch schneller. Das ist nicht messbar, würde ich mal behaupten.
Nee, auf deine selbst gekaufte Fritzbox kommen die nicht drauf.
Es sei denn, du hast das Web-Interface ins Internet freigegeben und hast ein kack Passwort.
Dann kommt aber nicht nur dein Provider drauf, sondern potenzial jeder.
Aber das macht man ja auch nicht und ist standardmäßig auch nicht so.
Leute, die Management-Interfaces ins Internet freigeben, sind eh Paints-Champ
und wollen es nicht anders. Warum macht man sowas? Warum geht man das
Management-Interface von irgendwelchen Geräten ins Internet hin frei?
Vorausgesetzt ist es nicht die Fall. Wenn Hersteller dumme default-Settings haben
und die Leute sich checken, dann lasse ich mir es ja noch irgendwie gefallen.
Aber Leute, die es absichtlich machen, verstehe ich nicht.
Nee, ich sage nicht, dass du das freigegeben hast, aber ich verstehe es nicht, dass es Leute gibt, die das machen.
Es gibt ja Suchmaschinen, da kannst du nach offenen Diensten im Internet,
formulieren wir das mal so, suchen. Da findest du Webcams und früher waren da auch teilweise Zugänge
zu irgendwelchen Kraftwerken und so dabei, wo ich mir dann auch immer denke,
was für brain-dead-Leute war das denn?
Was für den Preis-Jam ist? Den Preis-Jam habe ich abgeschaltet.
Das hätte ich vielleicht mal auf Twitter schreiben sollen. Den Preis-Jam habe ich abgeschaltet.
Die deutschen Shops, also erstens wollten sich die deutschen Shops nicht so gerne
Cronen lassen, da musste ich öfters mal tricksen, mit Server neu aufbauen
und IPs wechseln. Ich hatte dafür im Hintergrund so ein fertiges Ansible-Skript,
damit konnte ich das komplett machen, aber hatte keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Und was viel komplizierter war, die Shops haben halt ihre Layout-Struktur der Seite geändert,
wohingegen ich den Crawler immer hätten patchen müssen.
Und der Crawler, die sind nicht sonderlich schnell mit Patchen von deutschen Shops.
Also es war eigentlich nicht wirklich möglich, das sinnvoll zu maintainen.
Und ich hatte keinen Bock mehr, das kommt auch noch dazu.
Sollte ich mal ein Bonbon lutschen, schnell?
Ach wir haben einen Command dafür, das wusste ich selbst nicht.
Geil, siehst du mal.
Der Preisschirm war ein Profil, um die Preise von schwer verfügbaren Technikern und Nutzer
über die Verfügbarkeit zu erfüllen.
Das Projektgebiet war eingestellt unter Anwalt...
Ja, genau. Alter, Mod-Check.
Richtig high IQ Moderators hier.
Das gibt schon Commandos schneller, als ich mir das selbst überlegt habe jetzt.
Ist das Open Source? Nee.
Nope.
Steve Ballmer-Style. Kein Open Source.
Kommt drauf an, müssen wir uns mal überlegen.
Wobei Menschenhandel ist ja verboten.
Wobei Zeitarbeitsfirmen existieren auch. Dann kann man bestimmt mal Mods vermieten.
Ist der Hetzner-Count noch gültig? Nein.
Also ich denke nicht, dass der Hetzner-Count noch gültig ist.
Wenn ihr Ausrufenzeichen Hetzner im Chat macht, besteht dabei, dass es gültig ist bis Ende 2021.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich habe es nicht ausprobiert, ob der Count noch geht.
Vielleicht geht der Count ja noch. Keine Ahnung.
Aber nee, gibt es tatsächlich nichts Neues gerade.
Die sind alle noch im Urlaub.
Ich habe Ende letzten Jahres auch nochmal eine Mail hingeschrieben.
Und auch die Rechnung bei der Gelegenheit geschickt.
Und die sind alle nicht im Office gerade und noch zum größten Teilen im Urlaub.
Ich sage richtig, richtig auf Zack hier, high IQ Mods.
Ja, ja, ja, habe ich, habe ich. Ich habe es noch nicht rausgeschmissen.
Das lief hier über Cloudflare alles. Stimmt, stimmt.
Wenn man das hier aufmacht, kommt es bei Cloudflare raus,
die sagen, dass das Backend nicht erreichbar ist.
Was wurde aus dem Log von J-Kram auf der Arbeit?
Naja, ich war ja zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo das großartig angesagt war,
bei uns glücklicherweise nicht da.
Aber das, was ich jetzt mitbekommen habe, ist,
dass das soweit eigentlich ganz klimpflig gelaufen ist.
Max, du musst was trinken, du kriegst wieder Kopfweh.
Ich habe gerade was getrunken, kein Problem.
Ah, hier guck Cloudflare. Cloudflare ist der Meinung.
Your browser working. Cloudflare Frankfurt working.
Preischamp error.
Da wären wir jetzt nie drauf gekommen, dass mein Browser funktioniert.
Cloudflare geil. Pog.
Ja, nicht alles verraten.
Vor allem, weil man wahrscheinlich ein FBI-Backdoor
so gut über eine JavaScript-Seite einbringen kann.
Ja, ich weiß, ich habe es mitgekriegt.
Die übliche Geschichte war das ja wohl wieder.
Naja, so, ich muss mal kurz husten, ich muss mal kurz muten.
So, hoffen wir mal kein Corona hier.
Ich kenne jetzt schon drei Leute, die Corona haben.
Einer hat sogar Omnikron, Omnikron, Omnikron.
Aber der anderen, die anderen beiden, bei denen ist ja schon lange her.
Der eine hat das ganz am Anfang, der andere so in der Mitte.
Und jetzt der letzte, wie gesagt, den Canon heißt,
schließt bei mir auch Leute, die ich übers Internet kenne, mit ein.
Ich kenne jetzt Omnikron.
Benutzt ihr auch H2-DBs auf der Arbeit?
Ich muss mal kurz nachgucken, was das ist, ich weiß gar nicht, was das ist.
Nee, das sagt mir gar nichts.
Kenn ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung, also benutzen wir nicht.
Wir benutzen viel Java-Kram, aber das benutzen wir nicht.
Es gibt Leute, denen ist echt nicht mehr zu helfen.
Ja, das, das, das verstehe ich auch nicht so genau.
Ich hatte ja ein Video über das, über Log4j gemacht.
Und da waren auch, da waren teilweise auch ganz, ganz merkwürdige Fragen drin.
Ich will jetzt leider nichts ein, müsste ich mal durchgucken.
Aber da waren teilweise echt komische Dinge dabei,
wo ich mir gedacht habe, okay, wenn man das nur halbwegs verstanden hätte,
dann würde man das jetzt nicht fragen.
Ach ja, übrigens, was mir, was jetzt auch ja diese Woche gewesen ist,
wo ich ja nicht wirklich Bock drauf hatte,
ich habe wieder angefangen zu arbeiten am Dienstag.
Also ich habe jetzt tatsächlich, stellt es euch vor, Leute,
ich habe tatsächlich eins, zwei, drei, vier Tage gearbeitet jetzt.
Dieses Jahr schon, huge.
Und Dienstag muss ich wieder ran.
Und ich muss sagen, das war gar nicht so schlimm,
weil halt immer noch Homeoffice und nicht nach Frankfurt fahren.
Nach Frankfurt fahren ist eh was, wo ich keinen Bock drauf habe.
Ich glaube, das werde ich noch nicht mal machen.
Zumindest nicht mehr in dieser, wie soll ich sagen, in dieser Häufigkeit.
Ja, das ist ja bei uns normal.
Ich sage nur, das kann ich an der Stelle jetzt auch mal erzählen,
wo ich hier den Keeper xpsilon gerade sehe.
Wir haben bei uns ein System, das ist so alt,
also da reden wir schon gar nicht mehr davon,
dass es nicht mehr supported ist oder sowas.
Nein, nein, das System ist schon gefaked neuer und faked älter zu sein.
Und selbst diese neuere Version ist nicht mehr supported,
die eigentlich nur vorgibt, die ältere Version zu sein.
Ist das jetzt doppelt nicht supported?
Also konkret, wir haben ein ganz, ganz uraltes Oracle-Datenbanksystem.
Das ist richtig uralt.
Das ist keine Ahnung, Oracle 6 oder sowas.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Das ist Oracle von 2005 oder so.
Das ist uralt, uralt, uralt.
Und da kann ich gleich was zu sagen.
Also das ist wirklich massiv alt.
Ja, leider.
Also das ist richtig, richtig krass alt.
Und damit das überhaupt noch funktioniert,
ich glaube, das braucht ein Red Hat Enterprise Linux 4.
Von wann ist das?
Wann hatte das End of Life?
Eine Extended haben wir nicht.
Normales End of Life.
Extended haben wir dafür garantiert nicht gekauft.
OK.
2011.
Also wir haben ein System, das braucht Red Hat 4.
Und das ist vor zehn Jahren, elf Jahren, vor elf Jahren,
ne, doch vor elf Jahren ziemlich genau, vor elf Jahren ausgelaufen.
OK.
Was haben wir gemacht?
Man hat ein Red Hat 5 installiert
und hat dem Red Hat 5 in die Versionsdatei geschrieben.
Das ist glaube ich ETC Red Hat Release oder ETC Issue oder sowas.
Hat man reingeschrieben bei dem Red Hat 5, es wäre ein Red Hat 4.
Warum braucht man das?
Weil der Installer von der Oracle DB checkt, ob es ein Red Hat 4 ist.
So, dann kann man den Installer mit überlisten.
Das heißt wir haben einen als Red Hat 4 getarntes Red Hat 5.
Die Sache ist nur die.
Eigentlich ist auch Red Hat 5 seit sieben Jahren abgelaufen.
Seit acht Jahren abgelaufen.
Ist das jetzt doppelt, doppelt End of Life?
Weil es ist ja ein End of Life Red Hat 5, was faked, dass es ein Red Hat 4 ist.
Red Hat 6 ist glaube ich mittlerweile auch abgelaufen.
Einfach abschalten das Ding.
Ja, das ist mittlerweile abgeschaltet.
Aber nur halb.
Das wird manchmal noch eingeschaltet.
Welches System?
Ich meine das wahren Wirtschaftssystem.
Den genauen Namen sage ich dir jetzt nicht, aber ein wahren Wirtschaftssystem meine ich.
Ja, und das ist mittlerweile abgeschaltet.
Wird aber regelmäßig für alte Belege und sowas, wird es nur wieder eingeschaltet.
Ist eigentlich echt lustig.
Aber so Leichen hat man halt einfach.
Also wenn das Unternehmen nicht neu ist und halt gerade alles neu macht, wenn es nicht so startupmäßig unterwegs ist,
dann hast du halt früher oder später so alte Dinger.
Wäre es nicht besser gewesen gleich ein aktuelles Red Hat zu nehmen?
Doch, doch, wäre bestimmt besser gewesen.
Aber zu dem Zeitpunkt, als man das System aufgebaut hat, war wahrscheinlich Red Hat 5 aktuell.
Vermute ich mal.
Das wird wahrscheinlich irgendwann 2010 herum gewesen sein.
Da hat man das neu aufgebaut, weil das war ja dann hier End of Life.
Da hat man sich gedacht, okay, da haben wir jetzt noch ein bisschen Zeit.
Vielleicht kennt ihr diese Aussagen so nach dem Motto, ja, dann bauen wir das jetzt neu auf mit dem aktuellen, mit dem nicht ganz aktuellen System.
Aber weil da haben wir noch Zeit in vier Jahren, bis das abgelaufen ist.
Ja, bis dann ist das auch ganz bestimmt abgelöst.
Und was meint ihr, war es abgelöst?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Gatorius, verwende das ernsthaft noch jemand, ja?
Gatorius.
Irgendeine Frage gab es eben noch, die ich übersehen habe.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ich habe die Hälfte übersehen.
Kreator Dashboard.
Das ist ja fast schon, das ist ja fast schon.
So, achso.
Musst du eigentlich deine Kamera anmachen bei Home Office Meetings?
Nein.
Zum Glück nicht.
Die meisten Sachen sind ja auch irgendwelche spontanen Telefonate zu oder jetzt mal spontane Team Calls zu irgendwelchen Sachen, weil irgendjemand was wissen will, weil ich was wissen will,
weil irgendwelche Tickets-Sachen nicht klar sind, weil man irgendwas zusammen nachgucken will.
Das sind also die, sag mal so, 80% der Team Calls sind ja sowas.
Leider gibt es oft genug auch irgendwelches Gemiete und da haben wir zum Glück mittlerweile zum größten Teil die Kamera einfach aus.
Da muss man auch nicht gucken, dass man hier gerade ordentlich vorm Rechner sitzt und vielleicht doch irgendwie nicht mehr den Schlafanzug anhat oder sowas.
Meistens haben wir die Kamera aus.
Die einzige Sache, wo wir öfters mal die Kamera anhaben, ist unsere Teamrunde.
Ja, dass man sich einmal die Woche gesehen hat, das finde ich eigentlich auch ganz sinnvoll.
Aber ansonsten, glaube ich, habe ich so gut wie nie die Kamera an.
Wir haben ja leider abgeschaltet, dass man Custom-Avatare hochladen kann bei uns in Teams.
Sonst hätte ich meinen Yoshi wieder hochgeladen, aber nope, gibt's nicht.
Ist nicht Business Enterprise genug, wenn da Leute Custom-Avatare hochladen können. Das geht nicht.
Ich meine, das könnte man tatsächlich machen. Man kann ja so eine Fake-Kamera erstellen und die dann einschalten.
Das funktioniert ja.
Ich könnte auch einfach die OBS-Kamera verwenden und ein Ayaya-Bild rein machen.
Und dann die Kamera jedes Mal einschalten, damit die Leute alle das Bild sehen.
So, also, das wird tatsächlich bei uns manchmal nicht schlecht.
Was gucken wir uns denn heute an?
Chat, wenn ihr irgendwelche High-IQ-Big-Brain-Video-Vorschläge habt, dann sagt Bescheid.
Ansonsten gucken wir mal, was uns YouTube hier empfiehlt und ansonsten habe ich auch noch ein paar Dinge aufgemacht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich Linus immer empfohlen kriege.
Ich gucke das in letzter Zeit, also in letzter Zeit, es ist bestimmt schon zwei Jahre eigentlich gar nicht mehr.
Ist das die Rettung? Der große Plan mit der Deutschen Bahn.
Okay, das gucken wir uns nicht jetzt an, das gucken wir uns nicht jetzt an, ich mache das mal auf, das kann man sich vielleicht irgendwann mal angucken.
Wobei, oh nein, TOS, öffentlich-rechtlicher Kram.
Bezahlen wir alle mit, aber zusammen angucken, auf YouTube darf man das nicht.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das geht auf gar keinen Fall.
Warum Gender-Sprache scheitern wird, oh, das haben wir aber wieder richtig, richtig, die richtig kontroversen Hardcore-Themen heute Morgen.
Das Gender-Video war super, das guckst du mir aber nicht an, nicht an, jetzt 28 Minuten.
Guide for Pure Evil, guck mal, ein Echsenmensch-Zuck.
Vermute ich mal, weil er so grün ist.
Aber nichts toppt Obamas Echsenmensch-Bodyguard, das ist mit Abstand meine Lieblingsverschwörungstheorie.
Gaming on Linux, ja, das, okay, das können wir uns tatsächlich angucken, diese Linux-Challenge ist tatsächlich ganz witzig.
Zumal ich jetzt schon sagen kann, ja, dass Linux und Spiele zwar noch besser funktioniert als vor Jahren,
aber kein Vergleich ist mit Windows, man startet Steam und kann einfach irgendwas installieren, was man will und dann geht's.
Auch wenn ich dafür, ich hab das ja schon öfters in Videos gesagt, und auch wenn ich von Hardcore-Linux-Fans da immer heftig für kritisiert werde,
ich stelle das nach dem Wort, Max, man muss einfach nur wissen, was man macht, dann geht alles unter Linux und stelle ich ihnen immer irgendwelche Fragen,
auf die dann immer sehr, sehr ausweichende Antworten kommen, ja.
Ich frag die Leute dann zum Beispiel, ja, wie sieht's aus, keine Ahnung, mit League of Legends Anti-Cheat, wobei ich glaube, das funktioniert mittlerweile sogar.
Geht LoL immer noch unter Linux mit Anti-Cheat?
Es ging auf jeden Fall mal, ich weiß nicht, ob es immer noch geht, ja, okay.
Ja, man muss dann nach aktuellen Anti-Cheat-Sachen fragen, zum Beispiel, wie sieht's mit Warzone aus oder sowas,
und dann müssen die Leute halt sagen, oh nee, fuck geht nicht.
Und anstatt es dann zuzugeben, ja, Max, es geht tatsächlich nicht alles, kommen dann immer irgendwelche Ausreden.
Es ist halt einfach aktuell, es ist halt einfach noch so, da muss man nur mal in die WineDB oder so gucken und feststellen, okay,
es funktioniert viel mehr als die letzten Jahre über, aber es ist lange davon entfernt, eine casual, freundliche Experience zu sein,
wie Steam unter Windows und laden und installieren und geht.
Aber vielleicht haben wir ja Glück und wenn das Steam Deck eine Sache hinbekommt, dann ist es mehr Sachen unter Linux lauffähig zu machen,
wobei ich halt meine Frage habe, ob das Steam Deck in irgendeiner Art und Weise überhaupt die Leute interessiert.
Mittlerweile ist das ja raus, was war am Anfang, war das voll gehypt und ich habe mir damals schon gedacht,
wer genau will jetzt eigentlich so einen Steam Deck haben und du hörst über Steam Deck nichts mehr.
Obwohl die Dinger ja im Dezember verschickt wurden.
Ich musste mal ein Uni Projekt mit so einem Hardcore Arch, übrigens ich hab gehört, man darf nicht I use Arch sagen, wenn man mal Jaro verwendet.
Der hat zwei Stunden gebraucht im Android Studio zu installieren, weil der das unbedingt als Container machen wollte.
Als Container sollte es eigentlich doch noch einfacher sein, da musst du dich nicht um irgendwelche Abhängigkeiten kümmern,
sondern kannst, soweit die Theorie, den Kram einfach starten.
Achso, die sollten doch im Dezember mal verschickt werden.
So, na gut, dann lassen wir uns jetzt mal eine Runde von Level Cap Gbaiten würde ich sagen.
Okay, das ist ein Level Cap Video, Major Changes bedeutet bei Level Cap, irgendein Typ von Dias hat auf Twitter einen Furz gelassen
und jetzt kommen Major Changes. Gucken wir uns das mal an.
Kannst du die Musik ausmachen? Major Changes, das hat sich nichts geändert.
Mein Level Cap. Much more. Major, huge change.
What's unlocken ist so fehl. Habt ihr das mitbekommen?
Der Head of Communications Typ von Dias hat auf Twitter gepostet, nachdem sie aus dem Weihnachtsurlaub wieder da sind,
hat sich nicht so erfreut gezeigt darüber, dass die Leute so harsh angegangen werden von den Leuten,
weil die müssen doch auch mal Pause machen und sich ausruhen. Und ja, damit hat er, ich zeige euch den Tweet.
Ich glaube man muss einfach nur, wobei Reddit bestimmt, da ist Tweet gucken.
Was? Battlefield 2042 toxic subreddit may go down. Das habe ich in irgendeinem Videotitel vorhin auch schon gelesen.
Moment, ich will den Original. Wir gucken uns jetzt den Original Tweet an.
Der Original Tweet ist nämlich gar nicht schlimm. Es gibt eigentlich überhaupt nichts, denkt man erst mal so,
worüber man sich aufregen kann. Aber beim näheren Betrachten gibt es da doch einiges.
Hat jemand noch zufällig die Tweets?
Ja, das hat er gepostet. Was auch immer hier daneben.
Da hat er gerade zwei Tweets gepostet. Das ist ja eigentlich nicht schlimm. Das ist erst auf zweiter Ebene Kacke.
Was es zeigt ist, ich habe keine Ahnung ob man irgendwo den Tweet, keine Ahnung, wir bleiben jetzt mal bei dem Tweet. Also er hat ja nicht unrecht. Also ich gehe davon aus, dass da ist unter den aktuellen Bedingungen tatsächlich viele Leute hatte, die dort wirklich hart gearbeitet haben, dass Battlefield 2042 rauskommt 2021.
Nichts desto trotz. Deswegen ist der Tweet auch etwas unglücklich.
Zeigen die in letzter Zeit sich so disconnected wie noch nie von dem was sie machen, zu dem was die Community sich wünscht.
Zum Beispiel habt ihr mitbekommen, dass Rush wieder entfernt wurde. Der einzig spielbare Modus in Battlefield 2042 wurde entfernt.
Rush ist wieder weg. Ja, die Rush-Playlist ist wieder weg.
Ja, wurde entfernt vor ein paar Tagen. Also die sind richtig hart disconnected von dem was die Leute wollen und was sie machen. So und das eigentliche Problem ist, das ist ja das eigentliche Problem.
So wie er das hier geschrieben hat, aus ihrer Sicht, für die Leute die tatsächlich alles gegeben haben unter den Vorgaben und Bedingungen, also die Leute die nichts für die Entscheidung können, die da getroffen wurden. Für die ist es natürlich tatsächlich harte Arbeit und die haben da hart gearbeitet und die haben sicherlich auch verdient sich jetzt mal auszuruhnen.
Das Problem ist, wenn man das so schreibt, dann liest sich das einfach so wie, die Leute sind grundlos pissed. Die Leute sind aber nicht grundlos pissed. Die Leute sind pissed, weil das Game-Scheiße ist, in einem unfertigen Zustand rausgekommen ist und es so aussieht, als tut sich bis März in dem Spiel erstmal nichts mehr.
Und das bei diesem Launch. Also es ist äußerst unglücklich gewesen, das so rauszuhauen auf Twitter. So, da drum ging's. Ich weiß nicht ob ihr das mitbekommen habt, aber gucken wir mal das Video weiter.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Das ist alles nur vorgeschoben, Leute. Ich sag euch jetzt wie es ist. Das ist alles nur vorgeschoben, um den Leuten vorzugaukeln. Man würde etwas, also wenn man, wisst ihr was ich meine, wenn man, wenn man die Leute fragt so nach dem Motto und was ist euer Feedback und was haltet ihr davon, da fühlen die sich gehört und denken sie würden da was drauf geben.
Aber sie geben da nichts drauf, weil erstens haben die intern mehr als genug Daten, um zu gucken wer das macht und wer das nicht macht, sinnvolle Auswertung als irgendwie auf Twitter-Geflame da einzugehen.
Auf der anderen Seite hätte man quasi die kompletten Fehlschlag von Battlefield 2042 vermeiden können, hätte man mal auf ein paar Leute, die den Kram spielen gehört. Und man möchte nicht auf Leute, die das spielen hören.
Das sieht man an der puren Existenz von Battlefield 2042, so wie es jetzt ist.
Stimmt überhaupt nicht, das ist ihnen scheißegal.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla. Hätte man da wirklich Interesse dran und hätte man das gemacht, dann wäre Battlefield 2042 nicht in diesem Stand rausgekommen, wie es jetzt ist und hätte nicht so viele sinnlosen, schwachsinnigen Gameplay-Entscheidungen, wie sie jetzt drin haben.
Das Video vom Siegesmund habe ich geguckt, wir könnten das theoretisch auch noch mal irgendwann im Stream gucken, aber das ist halt glaube ich 40, 43 Minuten oder so lang, das ist mir heute ein bisschen vieles guten.
Denkst du Arc Raiders wird was werden? Keine Ahnung. Keine Ahnung, das sind ja viele von DICE, die da dran arbeiten, aber es ist halt was komplett anderes als Battlefield. Das ist glaube ich eher so ein Survival-Ding oder sowas. Keine Ahnung, weiß nicht, interessiert mich auch nicht so großartig. Ach nee, warte mal, Arc Raiders war das, wo die Leute so rumgejumpt sind mit Jetpacks oder sowas. Kein Schimmer. Ist jetzt nicht so, als hätte mich das wahnsinnig interessiert.
Ja, wir machen das Open Source Projekt fertig, also das Commit. Also wer es nicht mitbekommen hat, wir haben angefangen im Stream ein Commit für Uptime, also ein Feature-Pranche für Uptime-Kuma zu basteln und wir sind eigentlich fast fertig geworden, ich habe noch nicht weiter gemacht. Wir machen das fertig und machen Pulli-Quest auf dann. Vielleicht heute noch.
Portal! Eigene Portal-Server sind Hardcore-unsinnig, du kriegst keine XP richtig, ich glaube Waffen-Freischalten geht mittlerweile, oder? Bin mir nicht sicher, aber XP gibt es auf jeden Fall nicht und Portal ist dead. Ihr müsst euch mal Bilder angucken von der Konsole. Die erste Seite Portal-Server hat irgendwie insgesamt 20 Spieler.
Und das Portal keine XP, das ist ein Problem, das haben die einfach ignoriert. Das erste, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, was die gesagt haben als Portal, als das angekündigt wurde, nicht nur Portal, als auch Hazard Zone, also sie haben gesagt, Cross-Progression, du kannst spielen, was du willst und du bekommst überall Progression.
So, und dann haben sie festgestellt, was? Die Leute machen Booster-Server in Portal? Ja da hätte man ja nicht drauf kommen können im Vorfeld. Man erlaubt den Leuten quasi Settings zu machen, dass sie innerhalb von 5 Minuten die XP von 5 Stunden bekommen würden.
Ja, aber das machen die Leute doch nicht. Da hätte man doch nicht mitrechnen können, dass die Leute das machen. Und dann hat man sich gedacht, wir schalten einfach die XP ab und scheißen drauf, was wir im Vorfeld versprochen haben.
Weil es ist ja nicht so, als hätte man da nicht irgendwelche Regelungen finden können mittlerweile jetzt nach 8 Wochen oder so. Ich erinnere, ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen, ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch dran, als wir zusammen im Stream den Portal-Trailer geguckt haben und die das gesagt haben.
Das erste, wirklich legit, das erste was ich gesagt habe, was ist mit Booster-Servern? Vielleicht erinnert sich noch der eine oder andere der dabei war. Das erste was ich gesagt habe im Stream, Leute heißt das nicht, man kann Booster-Server machen und BÄM Booster-Server, DICE.
Da hätte man jetzt wirklich nicht drauf kommen können, oder? Oh man, so, wir gucken jetzt weiter. Leute, ich habe ein Problem, mein Headset spinnt. Ah, jetzt.
Ist es eigentlich laut genug? Ist es laut genug oder soll ich es ein bisschen lauter machen? Ach so eigentlich, oder?
Oh nein, jetzt kommt es, jetzt kommt es. Ja.
Die Sache ist halt auch die. Ich finde es tatsächlich, also wenn man ein bisschen nachdenkt, müsste man da nicht so ultra ausflippend drauf, weil man ja eigentlich weiß, was er gemeint hat.
Der hatte bestimmt nicht vor dem Stand des Games damit zu rechtfertigen und wie ich gerade gesagt habe, es haben trotzdem viele wahrscheinlich sehr hart daran gearbeitet, dass das in diesem Zustand rauskommt, überhaupt noch 2021.
Also klar, also auf objektiver Ebene hat er damit, hat er damit Recht. Problem ist das, was ich eben gesagt habe, als wir uns die Tweets angeguckt haben.
Hauptsächlich, dass es halt den Stand des Spiels runterspielt und es so klingt wie nach dem Motto, ist doch alles gut, ist doch alles super, regt euch mal nicht so auf, Spiel ist doch rausgekommen und taugt wunderbar.
Gut, der gleiche Typ hat auf Twitter auch geschrieben sein Lieblingsspiel, eines seiner Lieblingsspiele 2021 wäre Battlefield, aber gut, okay, da hat er dran mitgearbeitet, was soll er denn sonst schreiben.
Und den Leuten, auch mal aus Spieler-Sicht betrachtet, den Leuten bleibt ja auch gar nichts anderes übrig, als sich über sowas aufzuregen.
Was sollen sie denn sonst machen? Sie können ja das Spiel schlecht selbst patchen, das hat keine Modding-Tools oder sonst was, du kannst nichts selbst machen in diesem Spiel.
Okay, ja okay, es gibt Portal mit fünf Spielern, ihr wisst was ich meine, es ist nicht so, als könnte man grundlegend an dem Spiel was ändern.
Also dir bleibt ja als Spieler, der angepisst ist und 100 Euro hingelegt hat für ein unfertiges Stück Kacke, nichts anderes übrig, als sich darüber aufzuregen.
Und natürlich, es ist so, gerade auf Twitter und auch auf Reddit, es schießen dort alle gerne mal ein bisschen übers Ziel hinaus.
Aber, ich mein, bei dem shitfest was Battlefield 2042 ist, finde ich, ist das alles sogar noch irgendwie halbwegs im Rahmen.
Ich meine, die hätten ja auch ohne Probleme Pause machen können, das Spiel noch ein Jahr entwickeln und es dann releasen in einem besseren Zustand, hätte man ja auch machen können.
Also es hat ja keiner was dagegen, dass die Pause machen, aber ein unfertiges Spiel releasen und dann das in diesem Ton schreiben so nach dem Motto, ja, ist doch gar nicht so wild, wir müssen uns halt auch mal ausruhen, Spiel ist doch fein, was da so mit schwingt, das ist es halt nicht.
Und auch, wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass er es so gemeint hat, aber so kam es halt an.
Und dann so Dinge erzählen wie, Scoreboard ist ein Legacy Feature, Rush entfernen, obwohl es das einzig Spielbare in dem Spiel ist, ja.
Ja.
Ja, achja, das war der zweite Tweet, den ich meinte, den gab es auch noch.
Don't be sad, that's how... Sekunde. Don't be sad, that's how it works sometimes.
Er kann nicht so sagen, ah, Angel does it again. Rush ist wieder raus, ja, die Rush Playlist ist entfernt.
Du kannst nur noch Custom Server in Portal machen, aber die spielt da keiner. Also das einzig Spielbare haben sie rausgepatcht.
Das einzig Spielbare in diesem Spiel wurde entfernt, sehr gute Entscheidung.
Also sieht man wieder, wie disconnected die von der Community sind. Oder aber sie sind gar nicht so disconnected und das ist eine reine Stonks-Entscheidung.
In der Hoffnung, man erreicht somit auf lange Sicht mehr Leute. So nach dem Motto, wir entfernen Rush jetzt.
Die Leute rennen uns eh weg und in einem halben Jahr machen wir Rush wieder rein und dann kommen die Leute zurück.
Die, die uns jetzt weggerannt sind. Vielleicht ist das auch so. Ja, und das ist halt der nächste Tweet, wo die Leute auch richtig krass drauf angesprungen sind.
Dass er sagt, dass das, was die Leute erwarten, das was irgendwie brutal ist.
Also, so wie er das meinte, ist wahrscheinlich, ich glaube nicht mal, dass er da böse Absichten mit hatte mit diesem Tweet.
Er meinte wahrscheinlich, es ist ganz schön brutal zu erwarten von einem Entwicklerteam, dass sich quasi den Arsch aufgerissen hat,
dass überhaupt was passiert, um die Deadlines einzuhalten. Zu erwarten, dass sie auch über Weihnachten arbeiten.
Da hat er Recht. Was die Leute natürlich daraus rausgelesen haben, ist, dass es eine total brutale, überzogene Erwartung ist,
dass ein Spiel in spielbarem Zustand rauskommt. Das ist natürlich keine überzogene Erwartung.
Genau, so nach dem Motto, ist es zu viel verlangt, dass ein Spiel in spielbarem Zustand rauskommt.
Da gibt es doch dieses eine Meme dazu, so nach dem Motto, das ist, was er gesagt hat und das, was er denkt, was er gesagt hat.
Irgendwie sowas. Aber so in der Richtung ist das hier auch. Ich glaube nicht, dass er wirklich gemeint hat,
dass die Leute überzogene Vorstellungen haben davon, dass das Spiel in spielbarem Zustand rauskommen soll,
sondern eher, es ist bescheuert zu erwarten, dass die Leute, die sich das ganze Jahr über den Arsch aufgerissen haben,
an Weihnachten auch arbeiten sollen. Also wenn man mal 5 Minuten nachdenkt, kommt man da wahrscheinlich drauf.
Design and execute.
Many fans quickly pointed out that their aggression was less about the developers taking time away over the holidays
and moreover the lackluster State Battlefield 2042 launched in,
to which the developer responded with an apology stating that they only wanted to keep fans in the loop,
but will be more careful in the future.
The last communication reads, well, apologies to all, just wanted to fill you in on why there weren't updates,
I'll be more careful in the future. Happy New Year, Battlefield Peep.
Siehste, das ist so ein Ding, was ich an der aktuellen Kultur nicht mag.
Ich denke wirklich, dass das seine Meinung gut wiedergegeben hat, dieser Tweet.
Er hätte vielleicht nochmal klarstellen sollen, so nach dem Motto, selbstverständlich meine ich nicht,
dass das Spiel in diese, dass es eine, also er hätte klarstellen sollen, dass er nicht gemeint hat,
dass es eine überzogene Erwartung ist, dass ein Spiel in einem guten Zustand rauskommt,
sondern dass er gemeint hat, eben dass Leute, die sich das ganze Jahr über den Arsch aufgerissen haben,
das erwartet für das, die auch über Weihnachten arbeiten.
Das hätte er einfach nochmal klarstellen sollen.
So dieses generelle Entschuldigen mittlerweile für das, weil man mal was gesagt hat, geht mir echt auf den Sack.
Man sagt irgendwas, obwohl es seine vollste Überzeugung ist, danach shitstormen dich irgendwelche Leute
und man entschuldigt sich einfach mal pauschal wildcard für alles.
So nach dem Motto, alles was ich in meinem Leben jemals schlechtes gemacht habe,
ich entschuldige mich dafür und ich bereue alles zutiefst und ich werde mich bessern,
ich werde ein besserer Mensch werden, Leute shitstormen mich nicht weiter.
Ich finde, er hätte es einfach klarstellen können und gut wäre es gewesen.
Und wenn die Leute dann immer noch so abgehen, sei es halt drum.
Wie war das eigentlich bei Cyberpunk 2077?
Die haben das Vorbesteller Money abgegriffen und haben sich dann gedacht,
easy money, easy life.
Na mittlerweile gibt es ja wohl einige Patches, die last gen Konsolenvariante wird es wahrscheinlich nie wieder geben.
Weiß nicht, ob es da irgendwie jemals was passieren wird.
Und ansonsten sind die da dran, soweit ich das mitbekomme,
aber wohl noch weit von dem entfernt, dass das wirklich gut spielbar ist.
Hören sagen, keine Ahnung, ich habe es mir zum Glück nicht gekauft.
Ich hätte es mir fast gekauft, weil ich halt Witcher Fan bin und gedacht habe,
die bringen schon was Gutes raus.
Aber wisst ihr, was mich davon abgehalten hat, Cyberpunk vorzubestellen?
Das ist, weil das Setting und das Szenario überhaupt nicht meins ist.
Also ich hätte es nicht nicht vorbestellt, weil ich gedacht habe,
CD Projekt RED gibated und verarscht alle Leute.
Das hätte ich zum damaligen Zeitpunkt nicht gedacht, weil man sich halt gedacht hat,
jetzt auch sieht, dass es egal, was für einen guten Ruf irgendein Unternehmen in der Richtung hat,
wenn es um Stonks geht, wenn es um Money mitnehmen geht, dann macht man das.
Sondern ich habe es mir nicht bestellt, weil mir das Szenario an sich nicht gefällt
und ich erst warten wollte, was sagen denn die Leute da drüber,
was sagen Reviews drüber, was sagen Leute auf YouTube, wie ist das Game?
Ist das Spiel auch was für mich, obwohl ich das Szenario nicht mag?
Und die Frage hat sich mir danach gar nicht gestellt,
weil das Spiel war so unfertig und kaputt, dann ist es egal, ob ich das Szenario mag oder nicht.
Das habe ich nicht gekauft. Ganz im Gegensatz zu Battlefield.
Battlefield habe ich gekauft.
Das kenne ich schon. Sag mal, das ist auch, wisst ihr, die Frau macht mich übelst fertig hier in diesem Star Wars.
Das sieht original aus, wie die eine aus Titanfall. Nee, nicht Titanfall.
Wolfenstein New Colossus, glaube ich, war das.
Das sieht voll aus, Moment, Moment, guckt euch die mal ein.
War das New Colossus? Was suche ich denn da jetzt irgendwie Base, Team oder so?
Characters, Characters, Characters.
Characters, Characters.
Nee, nee, da ist die nicht dabei.
Diese Widerstandsanführerin, wo ist die denn?
Hm. Keine Ahnung, wie die hieß bei einem Spiel. Characters.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Find ich jetzt nicht.
Ja, dann nicht.
Ich glaube, die wollen Peter Aguilé haben.
Übrigens, mein LinkedIn ist immer noch nicht gelöscht.
Ist immer noch da. Meine anderen Links wurden alle gelöscht.
Irgendwie hat LinkedIn sich gedacht, den Account, den müssen wir...
Ich habe noch nicht mal das Login dafür. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich mich da einloggen kann.
Aber den Account gibt es noch. Ich glaube, das liegt daran, ich habe ja mal ein Video gemacht.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass LinkedIn so ein...
Wie nennt man das? So ein Flagging-Programm hat.
So ein bisschen wie Content Creator in Warzone, auch vom Anti-Cheat ausgenommen.
Vom Reporting für Cheats ausgenommen sind.
Wenn die das sehen, dass das irgendein YouTuber-Account ist, die damit halt Dinge zeigen,
dass sie das irgendwie flaggen, auch dass es halt nicht für Fake gebannt wird.
Wann kommen wieder Stellen anzeigen? Haben wir doch erst gemacht. Guck mal.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du es gesehen hast, aber es gab erst,
vor zwei Wochen welche, nämlich christliche agile Java-Zauberer.
Die unter anderem hatten wir da ein System-Administrator für ein junges christliches Unternehmen.
Erst mal eine Runde Brege.
Church Tools.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal das Video weiter.
Ich bin jetzt über eine Stunde on und wir haben es geschafft, 4 Minuten Level Cap zu gucken.
Man kann sich jetzt darüber streiten, was davon wirklich besser, doch das sieht schon besser aus.
Manche Sachen kann man doch auch einfach mal gut sein lassen, oder?
Mass Effect ist durch. Mass Effect wurde fertig erzählt.
Mass Effect hat mittlerweile mit den Adults auch einen guten Abschluss.
Andromeda hat schon keiner gebraucht.
Kann man sich einfach mal gut sein lassen, jetzt für 10 Jahre oder so? Mindestens.
Dann vielleicht mal wieder, aber kann man immer einfach sagen, okay, ist es jetzt abgeschlossen, ist es gut jetzt?
Ah, wer sonst?
Ja, das hat man auch schon öfters gehört.
Egal, sage ich nichts zu.
Wo wir gerade bei Remakes sind. Es ist ja nicht wirklich ein Remake, es ist ein Remake.
Es ist kein Remaster, es ist ein Remake, oder eine Neuinterpretation, aber ganz im Ernst.
Warum? Die Geschichte ist auch fertig erzählt. Und auch nicht mal, sondern nicht gut, aber sie ist fertig.
Ich meine, das letzte Modern Warfare, das habe ich mir noch irgendwie gefallen lassen, weil sie sich rausgeredet haben mit,
das wäre ja die Origin Story von Price sozusagen, so ein bisschen, ja, so die Vorgeschichte von MW1.
Also MW1 2019 war ja die Vorgeschichte von MW1.
Aber was wollen sie jetzt in MW2 machen? Soll Soap noch mal drauf gehen oder was?
Oder ist das jetzt paralleles Universum, wo alles noch mal passiert oder was?
Ach, naja.
Ja. Natürlich geht das zu Last-Gen-Konsolen. Natürlich. Natürlich.
Weil sie sich immer noch nicht alle PlayStation kaufen konnten.
Das ist mir scheißegal, ob die auf meinen Feedback, ob die listen.
Wenn schon, sollten sie listen und damit auch was Sinnvolles anfangen.
Also einfach nur zu sagen, ja, bitte, bitte schreibt uns Feedback hin und das Feedback direkt in den Mülleimer zu schmeißen, das können sie sich sparen.
3090 Ti. Ist die jetzt schneller als die 3090 oder ist das im Prinzip eine 3090 mit vernachlässig baggelringeren Specks zu kleinerem Preis?
Überlegt euch mal, wie krass die 3090 dann zur Release war. Wann war das Release Date? 2020? Guckt mal.
Die 3090 kam Ende 2020 raus und du hast jetzt bis jetzt quasi bis quasi.
Guck mal die 30 90 kam ende 2020 raus und du hast jetzt bis jetzt quasi bis quasi
eineinhalb jahre später
Hast du immer noch mit die schnellste grafikkarte und es wird auch auf absehbare zeit mit die schnellste grafikkarte bleiben weil als nächstes
Es müsste erst mal eine neue
grafikkartengeneration rauskommen damit das überhaupt ansatzweise was bringt und
ist ich bin immer noch mit meiner 1080 ti zufrieden
To announce the ryzen 7
5800 x 3d and this is amd's first processor to use its new vertical stacking 3d v-cache technology
was für moment moment das ist ja auch eine an eine aneinander reihung von
5 hat begriffen
5900 x 3d and this is amd's first processor to use its new vertical stacking 3d v-cache technology
3d v-cache technology
in the 5900 x core i9 12900 k theoretically it's the fastest gaming processor a title only
very recently self appointed by intel the ryzen 6000 series processors for laptops were also announced with of course the
Ryzen 7000 series desktop CPUs being revealed
später im Jahr. Intel hat auch ihre neuen Prozessoren
begonnen, beginnend mit dem 12. Gen KS-Series-Desktop-Prozessor.
Es baut massive 5,5 GHz Single Core Turbo aus der Box.
Die neuen H-Series-Mobile-Prozessoren wurden auch für Laptop-Prozessoren angeboten,
die sich um 40% über Intels Laptop-Prozessoren anbieten.
Was, was, was, was, was bin ich, was bin ich da sehend, was ist das?
Ah, Riders Republic, ok, schon nie was von gehört.
Sieht aus wie Sundance aus Battlefield 2042, nur in funktionierend.
Asus, wie wir alle wissen, dass es Asus heißt.
Ich glaube, ganz ehrlich, die erste Version
von diesen Masken, die Dinger sind ja überall ausverkauft gewesen, war eigentlich eher Just
for Fun als Gag gedacht und die waren davon selbst überrascht, dass das so gut ankommt.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus, wie das Ding, wie heißt diese Held, wie heißt die Heldinsel,
die Heldin in Valorant, die mit diesen Gift-Dinger und die hat auch so eine Maske auf, sieht
fast, Viper, genau, sieht fast aus wie diese Viper-Maske aus Valorant als Teil.
Dann signen wir auf, mal YouTube-Refreshen, mal gucken, ob die jetzt irgendwas neues
zu zeigen haben, nein, nope, branchless-programming in C++, genau, eine Stunde C++, genau, eine
Stunde C++ Talk, das ist genau das, was ich mir unbedingt jetzt geben muss.
Guck ich mir lieber den grünen Zug 16 Minuten an.
Aktuelle Corona-Zahlen juckt mich so überhaupt nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, das ist allgemein so, dass es mittlerweile einfach ins eine Ohr raus, nein,
ins eine Ohr rein und ins andere Ohr raus geht.
Ach ja, jetzt wo ich das hier gerade gesehen habe, erinnert sich noch irgendjemand an Venice
Unleashed, Battlefield 3 Mod bzw. eigentlich Battlefield 3 Modding Tools, ich habe sogar
noch installiert.
Zack, wir gucken mal kurz, wie viele Spieler, Moment, Venice, wo ist Venice, hier, VU-Klein.
Hast du hier schon mal SM2, was ist SM2?
Ich glaube nicht, das ist was mit Super Mario zu tun hat.
Ach du meinst dieses Modern Warfare, Disco of Duty-Ding, ja, da bin ich sogar im Discord
und guck mir das regelmäßig an.
5 Player, hui, huge, also das ist Venice Unleashed, das ist ein Modding Pack, Modding Tools für
Battlefield 3 und vor über einem Jahr haben die schon angekündigt, also nein, angekündigt
ist es schon länger, die haben vor über einem Jahr gesagt, dass ein Battlefield 3 Reality
Mod wohl rauskommen soll und jetzt ist es angeblich soweit.
Und wir gucken uns jetzt mal 3 Minuten Gameplay davon an und mal gucken, was sie da draus
gemacht haben.
Das letzte Mal, als ich mir einen Trailer angeguckt habe zu dem Reality Mod, als einzige,
was ich gesehen habe ist, sie haben das HUD ausgeplendet und hatten so ein Medic-System,
wo man hinlaufen muss und die Leute verbinden und nicht einfach eine Medic-Kiste schmeißen
kann, aber ansonsten sah das noch ziemlich Battlefield 3-ig aus.
Gucken wir mal was jetzt ist, angeblich kommt das jetzt, also angeblich soll das jetzt
auch wirklich bald erscheinen, ich bin ja bei denen auch im Discord und da tut sich
auch schon das ganze Jahr über was und angeblich soll es jetzt soweit sein, gucken wir uns
mal das Gameplay an.
Das ist cool mit der Map, das ist neu, das hatten sie das letzte Mal noch nicht, das
erinnert mich ein bisschen an Squad, mit der Map zum Zoomen, wo du deine ganzen Leute siehst.
Übrigens, übrigens, by the way, was ich jetzt an der Stelle auch nochmal sagen muss,
Battlefield 3 ist ja auch auf Frostbite und auf eine etwas ältere Version von Frostbite,
wo man sagen müsste, da waren die Tools und alles auch noch nicht so gut.
So, ähm, sprich, Fans schaffen es, Battlefield 3, ein Frostbite Spiel, was ja quasi angeblich
unmodbar ist, laut DICE, und so schwierig zu entwickeln, dass sie selbst nicht mal mehr
können richtig, schaffen es Fans zu reverse-engineeren, sich selbst Tools dafür zu bauen und Dinge
in das Spiel einzubauen, was ursprünglich gar nicht ging.
Also, das lässt mich weiter an der Fähigkeit von DICE in vielen Regionen zweifeln.
Der Battlefield 3 Sound kommt halt so auch besonders gut zur Geltung.
Na gut, aktuell ist es halt Battlefield 3 mit entferntem Hut und einem Kompass unten,
den hatte man in Battlefield 3 so nicht.
Ist das eine neue Map?
Das ist jetzt die Frage, ist das eine neue Map oder ist das eine alte Map?
Ich würde sagen, das ist eine alte Map, etwas angereichert mit neuen Sachen drauf.
Komm mal, du kannst sogar, du kannst sogar Kommandos auf der Map schicken.
Team Vodka, ke komrit, jawoll.
Wo hammern, ich finde meine Emotes nicht.
Also, also man muss sagen, in so einem realistischen Szenario fehlt eindeutig jemand, der sagt
ah, Angel, does it again, weil, weil so ist das nicht realistisch.
Aber das mit dem Zoomen der Map, guckt, vergleich noch mal eine reverse-engineert gemodete Battlefield
3 Map, ja, Moment, Moment, Moment, hier, das ist eine, ein Frostbite-Game von Leuten gemodet
mit Modding-Tools, die sie reverse-engineeren mussten, die keine Ahnung hatten davon, was
es ist, die nicht an der Entwicklung beteiligt waren und die bauen in dem Spiel eine Map
ein, die einfach mal um 500% besser ist als die Map in Battlefield 2042, weil die Map
in Battlefield 2042 hat ja nichts, noch viel schlimmer, dass auf der Map von Battlefield
2042 viele Sachen das gleiche Icon haben, obwohl es unterschiedliche Sachen sind.
Was das wohl werden könnte, wenn die offiziellen Support von DICE bekommen würden, gut, in
dem Fall kann man es schlecht sagen, ich kenne die Entwickler nicht, aber Battlefield 2,
wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, korrigiert mich, wenn ich falsch liege, aber ich glaube,
Battlefield 2 wurde auch zum größten Teil von Hardcore-Battlefield-Fans mitentwickelt.
Ich bilde mir ein, ich habe da noch sowas im Hinterkopf, die wurden dafür eingestellt,
warst du Hardcore-Battlefield-Fan und kannst Spiele entwickeln, bähm, mach für uns mal
ein Game, da kommt wahrscheinlich was Gescheites dabei raus, da kommt vielleicht nichts dabei
raus, was auf Vermarktung optimiert ist oder auf Microtransactions und sonstige Geschichten,
aber da kommt wahrscheinlich ein gutes Spiel dabei raus.
Das ist immer, diese Aussagen, diese Aussagen mag ich den MMOs auch immer, wenn man mit
Leuten den MMOs spielt, mit denen man sonst nicht spielt, so irgendwie Random Group,
und dann irgendwie einer sagt, ich bekomme Damage, ich bekomme gleich Damage, gleich
Damage, ich habe keine Ahnung, wer ich ist, ich kann die Stimme nicht den Charaktern zuordnen
nach zwei Minuten, wo ich die Gruppe gejoint bin, du musst sagen, Charaktername bekommt
gleich Damage, Charaktername XY bekommt gleich Damage, ich bekomme Damage, ich bekomme Damage,
das kannst du machen, wenn du mit Leuten schon drei Jahre zusammenspielst, dann weißt du,
wer ich ist, aber vielleicht ist das ja da auch so.
Das ist ja genau das gleiche, so geil, who is me, genau das habe ich mir auch genannt,
who the fuck is me.
Wer denn das gesagt hat, hat sich ein bisschen wie Peter von Microsoft zu Paul aus Indien
angehört, who is me, oh nein, Leute, ich habe das wirklich nicht vorher rausgesucht
oder so, es ist aber das erste, wo ich dran gedacht habe, weil ich bin ja gerade auch
ein bisschen MMO, Oldschool, uralt MMO Zeug, gerade ein bisschen Beta spielen, wieder nebenbei,
oder ist es halt einfach so, wenn du bei Leuten in die Gruppe joinst, unter anderem vielleicht
sogar mit Discord, und dann sagt dann einer, bekomme gleich Damage, ich habe keine Ahnung,
wer das ist, on me, who is me, ah der Battlefield 3 Sound ist schon ziemlich poggers oder, und
gerade bei so einem etwas langsameren, rumgestellten, stelle ich mir vor, kommt das besonders gut
zur Geltung, wobei man halt sagen muss, das ist ja jetzt ein Gameplay, Trailer, Reveal,
was auch immer, ob das im Endeffekt wirklich so taktisch gespielt wird, sei mal dahingestellt,
also wenn du nämlich immer noch unendlich Sprint hast und sowas wie in Battlefield 3,
dann ist easy, dann ist es quasi wie Battlefield 3 Hardcore, wo du durchaus jetzt einfach mal
dran Sprintest und sowas, mal gucken wie realistisch es sich dann wirklich spielt, die machen es
jetzt natürlich auch auf ultra realistisch, Alter was ein A-Amer, HC Mod und dann greifen
sie dann immer richtig, und jetzt mit Smoke wird hier gepusht, Medic unterwegs, aber
die Map, also das muss ich mal sagen, die Map haben die wirklich gut gemacht, also es
ist wirklich nice, und man muss sich mal vorstellen, das ist Battlefield 3, das ist nur halt das
Spiel mit reverse engineered Modding Tools, kannst du dich nicht beschweren, also das
ist wirklich poggers, besser als das was DICE hinbekommen hat, es erinnert mich ein bisschen
an Squatty Map, Rauchgranaten gibt es in Valhalla nicht, das stimmt, es gibt nur den Smoke Launcher,
also diesen Smoke Granatenwerfer gibt es, spielst du heute Reality Mod, das ist noch
nicht raus, wenn ja würde ich spielen, also ich wüsste nicht was für eine Map das aus
Battlefield 3 sein sollte, ich vermute das ist eine Battlefield 3 Map, die sie insofern
gemoddet haben, es gibt ja einen Map Editor, der kann aber keine neuen Maps erstellen,
der kann nur alte Maps editieren und ich glaube Gebäude setzen und sowas, also ich denke mal
das wird eine Armored Kill Map sein, die sie modifiziert haben, ich meine jetzt lohnt
sich in dem Fall sogar mal, ne das ist nicht Caspian Border, das ist nicht Caspian Border
oder ganz am Arsch der Welt von Caspian Border, aber da lohnt sich in dem Fall sogar auch
mal diese Sorte von Visiere, die benutzt ja sonst Battlefield 3 nicht und auch Singelschuss
lohnt sich da, das ist Armored Shield ok, da bin ich mal gespannt, wann ist denn Release?
Coming Soon, this time for real, ja angeblich sollte es nämlich schon Anfang letzten Jahres
oder vorletzten Jahres oder wann auch immer rauskommen, benutzt du einen RSS Reader?
Gucken wir mal auf die Webseite, ob da irgendwas von Release Date steht, wie gesagt ich bin
seit zwei Jahren oder so bei denen im Discord, da gibt es regelmäßig Commits und Sachen
und Change Logs oder was heißt das, also Commit Messages, also ich wusste, dass sie da dran
arbeiten, aber dass es jetzt demnächst kommt, ist jetzt neu, aber das dürfte dann wahrscheinlich
tatsächlich als der besten Battlefield sein, den wir aktuell spielen können.
Es gibt kein Release Termin, naja, schauen wir mal, wann es denn dann soweit ist, nein
das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht nochmal Level Cap an, irgendwann ist auch mal gut, so was
schauen wir uns jetzt als nächstes an, zeig mal her, äh, keine Ahnung, Dark Side of Open
Source, What Really Happened to Faker.js, ne, kein Flat Earth Zeug heute, Advanced Shit
Techniques, warum habe ich so viel Fireship auf, der Chat-Channel ist übrigens richtig
gut, damit man weiß, was der Mensch endlich sagt, hä, was denn, achso, ja das kenne ich
schon, das kenne ich schon seit 5 Jahren, das Original Resitas, wo er seine Pfannen
ins Meer gestellt hat und dann die Flut gekommen ist und die Pfannen weggespült hat, das ist
ja schon, also, Weird Champ, Weird Champ, wer das noch nicht kennt, richtig Weird Champ,
danke für den Sub, ach und auch Max07, danke für den Sub, 13 Monate, richtig High IQ, Massive,
so, wo wir uns denn heute an, wir gucken uns jetzt Dark Side of Open Source an, kann schon
mal was der, was er da erzählt, aber, oh, ok, wir gucken nochmal von vorne, nein, das
Linus Gaming Video haben wir noch nicht geguckt, ne, ja, Faker.js, wenn ich weiß, was Faker.js
ist, kann ich vielleicht auch mal kurz erklären, das ist, wenn du, was programmierst, das Benutzer
Daten entgegennimmt, ja, Straße, Name, Telefonnummer und sowas und du bist gerade in der Entwicklung
und hast einfach schlicht und ergreifend noch nichts in deiner Datenbank stehen oder darfst
nicht mit echten Datentesten oder was auch immer, ne, das gibt's für dotnet auch, das
gibt's für nahezu jede Programmiersprache, Faker.js generiert ja Fake Benutzerdaten,
ja, Name, Adresse, Telefonnummer, Postleitzahl, alles, alles, also die haben total viel Zeug,
was es generieren kann, das ist sehr praktisch.
Oh, der Teufel, erstmal, erstmal Teufel austreiben, Preige.
Oh, jetzt kommt Fascherons Theorie, Reddit, Reddit, Reddit, Reddit, Reddit, Reddit, Reddit,
Reddit.
Okay, das ist schlechte Idee.
Return all the downloaded documents, hat er den dann USB Stick zurückgegeben oder was?
Returnen, was, okay, das ist, das ist, wenn Anwälte irgendwas machen, wovon sie keine
Ahnung haben, wie gibt man gedownloadete Sachen zurück, also auf USB Stick, vor allem, wie
will man sagen, das ist, das, egal, was, alter, die Amis, die Amis mit ihren Freiheitsstrafen,
Alter, und vor allem, was ist Wire-Fraud auf Deutsch, Kabelbetrug, die Amis mit ihren
Strafen, Alter, wieder, bei den Amis werden ja teilweise auch Leute zu 600 Jahren verurteilt
und sowas, das ist, ja, alles, digitaler Betrug.
Oh, das wusste ich gar nicht.
Ja, nicht motiviert sein bei Money war wahrscheinlich das Problem.
Aber jetzt kommen wir wieder zu unserer ersten Frage.
Was passiert mit Faker.js?
Wenn du nicht mit dem Thema bist, ist es eine sehr populäre Bibliothek mit über 1 Millionen
täglichen Downloads, die verwendet werden, um faken Daten zu kreieren, wie Namen, Telefonnummern,
Adressen und so weiter.
Ich habe mich schon gar nicht geklärt.
Ich habe viel Zeit gebeten, die Demo für diesen Kanal zu bauen.
Es wird von einem GitHub-User behält, den ich in diesem Video nicht erwähnen werde.
Diese Person hat eine sehr wichtige Frage, die viele Open-Source-Developer betreffen.
In seinen Worten, respektvoll, werde ich nicht mehr für Fortune 500 unterstützen.
Es gibt nicht viel mehr zu sagen.
Nimm diese Möglichkeit, mir eine 6-Figure-Jährliche-Kontakt zu senden, oder das Projekt auszuweichen
und jemand anderes zu arbeiten.
Die Antwort aus der Open-Source-Kommunikation war extrem positiv.
Das ist eine sehr traurige Realität.
Das kann ich verstehen.
Wenn Faker quasi von allen möglichen Multi-Milliarden-Dingern verwendet wird und die eigentlichen Maintainer
dort nicht über die Runden kommen, ist das eine Sauerei.
Man hat das bei Log4j gesehen.
Log4j, eine Library, auf die sich so ziemlich alles in der Java-Welt verlässt, maintint
von irgendwelchen zwei Leuten, die das nebenbei für ein paar Stunden die Woche machen.
Nice.
GG Eats.
Ja, KFC hat bestimmt kein Geld, KFC und Adobe haben, na gut, Yahoo, Yahoo hat wahrscheinlich
wirklich kein Geld mehr, aber die haben ja alle bestimmt kein Geld, um dem ein bisschen
was zu bezahlen für das Maintain.
Bestimmt nicht.
Das reicht nicht, diese 500 zusammen.
Ja, und was ist jetzt mit Faker.js passiert?
Also wahrscheinlich nichts, die hatten einfach keinen Bock mehr, das zu supporten, okay.
er hat das Video re-uploaded, wahrscheinlich haben sich die Leute wieder aufgeregt.
So, was haben wir denn hier, Fenster und Türensensor, the best door in Windows ist vom Aquaria,
deswegen habe ich, also nein, das stimmt nicht, dass ich das deswegen habe.
Ich habe das, weil es billig war, Mistakes were made, warum habe ich das geöffnet, was
ist das Thumbnail, Moment, ich muss mir angucken, was das Thumbnail von dem Video ist, vielleicht
habe ich deswegen geöffnet.
Was hat denn sein Fiber gekillt, Fiber, China-Chinesen Netzwerktools, das ist eine gute Idee, der
hat keine Outdoor-Kabel verwendet, ja, mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich habe auch nur an
einer Stelle Fiber gehabt, obwohl mein Switch 12 SFP Plus Modul hat, wo normalerweise Fiber
reinmacht, ich habe das meiste mit Direct-Attached-Kupfer-Kabel gemacht und ein Fiber hatte ich, also
ein Fiber-Kabel, das habe ich damals von der Arbeit gesponsort bekommen, als wir das Rechenzentrum
umgebaut haben, ausgebaut haben, wie auch immer, da gab es ein paar Fiber-Kabel, die
wir weggeschmissen hätten, habe ich gesagt, wisst ihr was Jungs, nehmen die mit und das
hatte ich mal, als ich noch die fette 4HE-Kiste dran hatte, hatte ich das zwischen dem Switch
und meinem NAS nicht mitgehen lassen, ich habe das wirklich offiziell gefragt, ob ich
das mitnehmen kann und da hieß es, kein Problem, dann wollte ich jetzt natürlich an der Stelle
mal bestreiten, weil ihr wisst, aus seinem Kündigungsgrund, ne, habe ich gesagt, kann
ich das mitnehmen und dann haben alle einstimmig gesagt, ja, vor allem wird eh weggeschmissen,
kein Problem, was bei uns auf der Arbeit, vielleicht kennt das einer von euch, was bei
uns immer ein Riesenakt ist, wir haben schon öfters mal gefragt, ob es möglich ist, alte
Notebooks günstig, günstig zu bekommen, ja, ja, das lag im Müll, ist das hier was dagegen,
wenn ich das mitnehme, ne, was wollte ich jetzt sagen, die Datenschutz im Kabel, genau, was
bei uns richtig Paynes-Champ ist, ist die Geschichte mit, wir haben gefragt, ob es möglich
ist, dass man günstig alte Notebooks bekommt und nein, ist nicht möglich, die verschrotten
das lieber oder verkaufen es für ein Euro an irgendeinen Broker, das verstehe ich auch
nicht so genau, aber gut, tja, es ist durchaus möglich, dass die Leute, die da waren, es
eigentlich nicht erlauben durften, aber who cares, Azubi technisch, ja, bei euch sind
die Dinger geleast, ne, die Notebooks sind bei uns nicht geleast, glaube ich zumindest,
aber die Smartphones haben sie bei uns geleast, das Notebook ist nicht kaputt, die Notebooks
sind meistens nicht kaputt, die sind halt einfach nur älter.
Aha, kann sein, würde mich aber wundern, zumindest, die verkaufen sie ja weiter, sie
geben es an irgendeinen Broker, der die dann weiter verschrachert, ne, zumindest die Kabel
mitnehmen, und ich habe die noch nicht mal mehr im Einsatz jetzt, so, kannst du einen
guten Staubsaugerroboter empfehlen, ist die Frage, was du machen willst, also muss es
komplett chinafrei sein oder nicht, ansonsten bin ich dabei eigentlich schlecht darin dir
einen zu empfehlen, weil ich habe zwei, einen davon benutze ich gar nicht mehr und einen
davon ist jetzt auch nicht mehr der neueste und geilste, ja, das hat die damals beim Provider
nicht gejuckt, das war ja noch bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber und das war denen alles wurscht,
wir haben damals sogar alte Desktoprechner mitnehmen dürfen, die weggeschmissen wurden,
das waren Alternate-PCs, die sie damals billig zusammengeschraubt haben, da durfte ich damals
einen Pentium 4 noch mitnehmen, kannst du dir vorstellen, das ist alles schon ein bisschen
her.
Markldm, danke schön, 19 Monate Hypersubscription, ja danke, jetzt geht es aber richtig ab, ja,
gute Frage, which, which robot should I buy?
Er gibt nicht so viel, ne, gibt, gibt, gibt, gibt leider nicht so viel, die patchbar sind,
der S6 muss man glaube ich aufschreiben sogar und der S6 ist nicht so aktuell, can man die
alle patchen, Dreamy, Dreamy Z10 Pro, get it right now, Dreamy Z10 Pro, Dreamy, Dreamy,
ja den S5 habe ich auch, der funktioniert aber der S5 ist halt nicht mehr das neueste
Ding, Dreamy Z10 Pro kostet 419 Euro, das ist doch, das ist doch ein rebrandeter Roborock
oder, der sieht original so aus, nur in schwarz, auch mit den Bürsten so, das ist doch die
China-Chinesen gucken untereinander von sich jetzt schon ab, das hat das staatliche Ministerium
für Staubsauger-Roboter-Design gemacht, man gibt sogar Absaugestation, gibt es die Absaugestation
dabei, ach Moment, das ist nur die Absaugestation oder, oder was, oder wie, ist das jetzt der
Roboter oder die Absaugestation oder beides, ich meine Bild, der Bild kann man ja nicht
wirklich viel drauf geben, Moin, tatsächlich guck mal das ist mit beidem, Moment, Geizhals,
vielleicht ist das wirklich was was ich mir mal geben konnte, ja alles akzeptieren, alles
klar, da ist beides dabei oder, noch buchst billiger, das ist günstig, nehmt ihr noch
ein Roborock, ne der ist nicht flashbar, brauche ich China-Chinesen Zeug für, nicht schlecht,
liefertermin unbekannt, ja super, wo ist es denn noch lieferbar, lagernd, cyberport, ja
es sei meinetwegen, schau mal Lieferumfang, Staubsauger-Docking-Station-Säuberungstool,
ist die Docking-Station das, oder haben die noch ne extra Docking-Station ohne Säuberungsstation,
also wenn hier, ganz ehrlich, bei diesem Bild, wäre die Station nicht dabei, wäre das Hardcore
oder, G-Bate, ja man kann die Dinger teilweise flashen, hier, glaub so, wenn wir Glück haben
ist das sogar noch im Chat, der ist manchmal sonntags morgens oder auch so, bei uns hier
im Chat der Schöpfer von Valetudo, hoffe ich spreche das ordentlich aus, ja, damit kannst
du es flashen, dann bekommst du ein Web-Interface mit Features, ähnlich zur App, manche Sachen,
die du gar nicht machen kannst in der App, zum Beispiel mehrere Stockwerke, zumindest
ging das ne Weile nicht, ich weiß nicht wie es jetzt aktuell ist, und das beste ist halt,
du brauchst halt kein China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Das ist ziemlich gut, das gefällt mir, ich glaube, ich, ich, also ich bin geneigt dazu,
das zu bestellen, mit Absauge, weil ich finde, mit Absaugestation ist ein Komfortstand erreicht,
wo du dich nicht wirklich groß drum kümmern musst, und das finde ich gut, du musst nur
ab und zu mal die Beutel, du musst nur ab und zu mal die Beutel wechseln, bam, Deep,
Gachi-Base, ich speichere mir das mal, ich werde mir das wahrscheinlich nachher bestellen,
nach dem Streamen, ja, das kann man flashen, steht hier, getting started, habe auch gerade
geguckt, Newcomer-Guide, Z10, Z10 Pro, Support ist gut, Developer-Support, yes, tested working,
yes, recommended, get it right now, Arch, by the way, rooting-instructions, zeig mal
her, wie rootet man das Ding, Z10, rootet man mit, do not update, firma via OTA, ok,
oh MonkaS, das ist schon wieder der Catch hier, wenn es mit neuer Firmware ausgeliefert
wird, geht es wieder nicht richtig, oder wie, das ist natürlich blöd, wenn es mit neuer
Firmware nicht geht, ich denke nicht, dass es schon die neueste Firmware hat, weil die
Chinesen, die sind nicht so schnell mit verteilen der neuen Firmware auf ihre Geräte, warum
sie dich angepinkt haben, keine Ahnung, es ging gerade um Staubsauger-Roboter und ich
habe gesagt, manchmal ist der Schöpfer dieser Firmware auch bei uns im Chat und irgendjemand
hat dich gepinkt, keine Ahnung, der Carlson, danke schön für 6 und 2, alter was, krasser
ab, 26 Monate Subscription, huge hyper Subscription, aber jetzt wo du gerade da bist, wie safe schätzt
du das ein, wenn man sich jetzt einen, einen Trimibot Z10 Pro kauft, wie hoch ist die Chance,
dass man die Firmware kriegt, die nicht mehr OTA flashbar ist, oder die nicht mal, nein,
die Firma, die nicht mal gescheit geroutet werden kann, also ich schätze es ja nicht
so hoch ein, weil die Chinesen meistens nicht so schnell sind, ihre Geräte damit auszuliefern,
aber man weiß es halt nicht, also bislang waren nur die gepatcht, der Rest war problemlos
routbar, ich glaube ohne Scheiß, ich glaube ich bestelle mir nach dem Stream ein und das
probieren wir da mal zusammen aus, was heißt OTA in diesem Kontext, dass du keine Kabel
dran machen musst, dass du over the air flashen kannst, die routing how to, zeig mal her,
jetzt ist das mir zu big brain, mit Kabel ist easy, ok dann kommt man wahrscheinlich
dran, ich kann mich nur dran erinnern, ich hab mal den, nice gucken wir uns an, ich hab
mal den Guide gesehen für den Roborock S6, der Typ in dem Video hat komplett das Gerät
zerlegt, dann musste er das Ding über Batterie powern, Kabel anlöten dafür, also das hätte
ich zwar prinzipiell alles hinbekommen, aber ich hätte es wahrscheinlich nie wieder zusammen
gebaut bekommen, also ich hätte das Ding wahrscheinlich geflashed und danach wäre
das Ding useless gewesen, der S5 ging noch gut, den habe ich ja auch hier im Einsatz,
also zeig mal her, wie geht das, also das ist übrigens das Webinterface, was man bei
der Software kriegt, root, suchen wir mal, routing instructions, oder wie die Cisco Leute
sagen, Routing Instructions, ok wie rootet man den Tremey, ich muss meinen Roborock tatsächlich
wieder updaten, weil der hat sich resettet, ich hatte noch irgendwie eine Firma drauf,
die ab und zu mal diesen Werksreset hatte und ich hab es aber seitdem nicht mehr gemacht,
ich hab in letzter Zeit muss ich ehrlich sagen, ich weiß, ok Boomer und so, ich habe in letzter
Zeit tatsächlich gesaugt mit dem Staubsauger, also mit dem großen Staubsauger, den man
in die Wand steckt, in die Steckdose, weil der Roboter fährt halt einfach mal eineinhalb
Stunden rum, bis der sauber hat und wenn ich mal schnell Staub wegmachen will und nehme
den normalen Staubsauger, dann dauert es halt 10 Minuten, ich bin durchgeflitzt überall,
das ist halt was ganz anderes, es ist sehr unagil, ja ich weiß, das ist nicht, nicht
DevOps Agile Daily Scrum geeignet, aber es geht schneller, moin Patrick, also wie Reset
Button, this was patched in many new Firmwares, do not upgrade, ne mach ich nicht, ich upgrade,
ich werd garantiert nicht upgraden, injecting custom OTA Upload including Hooks for, ok,
try this, you will only need 3,3 Volt USB to TTL, hab ich, hab ich, hab ich glaub ich ein 20er Pack noch hier, für den Fall der Fälle, das braucht man, braucht man immer wieder, also hab ich genug davon da, Jumperkabel hab ich auch da, Basic Linux Knowledge krieg ich auch grad noch hin,
ach guck mal, man kommt ja direkt an die, an die Pins dran, das ist mal, da waren die Chinesen
mal freundlich, da das chinesische Ministerium für Staubsauger Roboter Design gesagt, lasst
mal die Anschlüsse da, wir müssen da custom Firmware drauf installieren mit Staats-Trojaner,
aber für uns ist das auch gut, ja, agreege, ok das krieg ich gebacken, das ist easy, do
not connect, kurz Schluss, to get the password, ja wir machen das eh alles live im Stream,
dann leake ich erstmal mein Staubsauger Routepasswort, allein schon der Satz, Leute, ich leake mein
Staubsauger Routepasswort, da, da muss man doch eigentlich von ausgehen, dass man sie
nicht mehr alle hat, oder, wenn man sowas sagt, aber so, da sind wir halt, da sind wir
halt angekommen 2021, da kann man auch mal aus versehen im Twitch Livestream sein Staubsauger
Routepasswort leaken, ich hab's ja auch nicht, das ist wohl wahr, ja, 2022 stimmt, ja ihr
habt Recht, ihr habt Recht, Leute, das Ding bestelle ich mir, das Ding bestelle ich mir
direkt nach dem Stream, was ist mit Winforms, ja Winforms ist eklig, Qt ist eklig, weil
C++ Winforms ist alt und outdated, WPF ist ein bisschen weniger alt, aber auch aus outdated,
äh, wie kommt ihr denn jetzt überhaupt da drauf, wie kommt ihr da drauf, achso, gibt
es eigentlich in 2022 irgendeinen sinnvollen Weg GUI auf Windows, du kennst die Antwort
wahrscheinlich schon, aber du willst sie nicht hören, oder?
Es tut mir ja selbst in der Seele weh, ja, ich weiß nicht, wie es mit Flutter auf dem
Desktop aussieht mittlerweile, was JetBrains Compose, okay, gibt es ernsthaft eine ordentliche,
oh, guck mal da, was ist das, was ist das, also JetBrains traue ich das zu, ein ordentliches
Cross Platform GUI Framework zu machen, ja, du kannst, es gibt auch für C Sharp Qt Bindings
oder die offiziellen Python Bindings, aber es ist schon eine Weile her, da ich mich damit
beschäftigt habe, ich habe aber noch im Hinterkopf, dass alles andere als C++ ein bisschen Pain
in the ass ist mit Qt, wahrscheinlich aber auch erst, wenn du ein bisschen advancedere
Sachen machen willst, okay, zeig mal her, Compose multiple Fast Reactive Desktop und
C Sharp QoS Framework, okay, es ist Java Stels, muss es ausgerechnet Java sein, okay, es ist
nicht Java, es ist JVM, es ist Kotlin auf JVM, können wir das net vielleicht, dann meine
deswegen sogar Javascript, muss es wirklich Java sein, na gut, es ist JetBrains Zeug,
ja, ergibt schon Sinn, es ist schlimm, ne, Microsoft ist mit dran schuld, dass wir so
viele Electron Anwendungen haben, Microsoft hat es 20 Jahre nicht hinbekommen, naja gut,
15 Jahre nicht hinbekommen, ein ordentliches modernes Desktop UI Framework zu machen und
Windows ist nun mal auf dem Desktop die führende Plattform, bei Apple ist das kein Problem,
das ist kein Ding, da gibt es sowas und deswegen haben die Leute wahrscheinlich auch zunehmend
angefangen Web Anwendungen in Electron zu packen für Desktop, ich mein, was gibt es
unter Windows, es gibt Windows Forms, kannst du komplett vergessen heutzutage, ist zwar
immer noch die einfachste Variante, muss man sagen, Windows Forms an sich ist relativ easy
und schnell gemacht, fühlt sich aber an wie aus dem letzten Jahrtausend, weil es ist aus
dem letzten Jahrtausend, moderne Sachen wie beispielsweise Colour Emojis, kannst du ja
mal komplett, also wer das hier anzeigen lassen will, in der Windows Forms Anwendung hat gelicken,
guckt euch mal an, hier zum Beispiel Notepad, da kann man schon froh sein, wenn der Shit
funktioniert mit schwarz-weiß Emojis, ihr könnt übrigens relativ, wie heißt das andere
Wordpad, ihr könnt relativ easy testen, auf was Windows Anwendungen basieren, wenn die
noch oldschool sind und Windows Forms oder WPF verwenden, dann gehen keine Colour Emojis
und wenn ihr irgendwas neues verwendet, dann ist es wahrscheinlich noch UWP basiert, aber
UWP sackt halt einfach as fuck und Microsoft hat es bis jetzt nicht hinbekommen, ich glaube,
das ist jetzt gerade immer noch in Alpha Version, dass man mit der UWP WinUI Technologie, genau,
das ist mit WinUI 3, da will ich jetzt gerade was zu sagen, dass man mit der WPF UI Technologie,
Itami, danke schön für den Zap, dass man endlich die UWP UI Technologie verwenden kann
in einer unpackaged normalen Windows Anwendung, weil UWP ist einfach kacke, UWP ist halt Restriktion
ohne Ende und das schlimmste an UWP für mich ist, als Entwickler, dass man ein gültiges
Codesigning Zertifikat braucht, ich will irgendwie Mini Open Source Tool basteln mit einer hübschen
GUI dabei und ich soll mir erstmal ein Codesigning Zertifikat kaufen und das Ding signen oder
was, was ist das billigste Codesigning Zertifikat, was man sich so kaufen kann, 200 Euro im Jahr,
ich habe keine Ahnung, aber viel billiger wird es wahrscheinlich nicht sein, also es
ist wirklich richtig, richtig pains jammed, zum Test kann man es doch selbst signen, ja
ja, aber das bringt mir ja nix, wenn du eine Anwendung gebastelt hast mit UWP und willst
sie nicht über den Windows Store distributen, was du ja normalerweise nicht willst, sondern
willst einfach sagen, pack auf Github, mach im Release Tab ein Download, dann brauchst
du ein gültiges Codesigning Zertifikat oder deine User bekommen nach dem Download ein
riesen großes Fenster, diese Software ist nicht vertrauenswürdig und du kannst glaube
ich gar nicht installieren, ohne dass du Adminrechte hast, weil du musst quasi das Selbstsign Zertifikat
erst in den Store importieren, was, das kannst du vergessen, das kannst du komplett vergessen,
deswegen machen die Leute auch alle ja noch WPF und Windows Forms Anwendungen, weil es
nix gibt, man muss sich mal vorstellen, das neueste für Windows UI, was sich generell
für alle Anwendungen eignet, ist WPF, ein Ding was auch schon 15 Jahre alt ist und finde
ich von Anfang an bloated as fuck war, mit dem komischen XML Gedönster, ich bin da nie
mit warm geworden, also kein Wunder, dass die Leute alle Elektron verwenden, das hat damit
überhaupt nix zu tun, das ist ja was ganz was anderes, das ist Schrift Satz, warum überhaupt
noch Web Anwendungen, ja es gibt ja Anwendungen, zum Beispiel irgendwas, was ich spiele, Overlays,
Voice Chat Geschichten oder sonst was, wo es nicht verkehrt ist, wenn du Betriebssystem
Access hast und weil es nicht zu vergessen, weniger RAM braucht, in der Regel schneller
gestartet, dass er noch performanter läuft, wenn es was ist, worauf das ankommt, ich meine
für die 08-15, für die 08-15-Wetter-App ist das egal, Maui ist auch Müll, erstens
Maui unterstützt kein Linux, was ich verstehen kann, weil Linux Desktop ist auch Massive
Pain in the Ass, aber sollte sein und ist auch möglich bei so Sachen wie Flutter, weil
Flutter ihre Bedienelemente selber zeichnet, was Maui nicht macht, Maui ist eine Weiterentwicklung
von Xamarin und die verwenden Native UI Elemente mit einer gemeinsamen API oben drüber, also
das finde ich ist prinzipiell der komplett falsche Ansatz, dementsprechend können die
wahrscheinlich auch kein Linux Desktop gescheit supporten oder wollen es nicht oder ist ihnen
zu großer Aufwand, ja also ich finde den technologischen Ansatz von Xamarin oder Maui doof und das
Linux nicht supportet wird doppelt doof, also für mich nicht, also wenn man jemals Kernel
aufrufe oder sagt man mal, irgendwelche muss ja nicht mal Kernel aufrufen sein, wenn man
jemals Zugriff auf Betriebssystems Sachen aus dem Browser rausbekommt, dann ist aber
wirklich Hardcore-Pains-Champ angesagt, dann sind der Tür und Tor offen, das wird nicht
passieren.
Vielleicht für extra installierte PWAs oder so, da könnte man sich das nochmal überlegen,
für PWAs wäre das tatsächlich was cooles, da müsste man aber auch sicherstellen, dass
es echt doppelt dreifach abgesichert ist, dass PWAs nur installiert werden können auf
Fusor-Verlangen, ja zum Beispiel gibt es ja einiges, wie gesagt das erste was mir jetzt
einfällt ist zum Beispiel, wenn du irgendwelche Performance-Sachen abfragen willst, von Ram-Auslastung
bis CPU-Takt oder so was, oder du willst ein FPS-Overlay machen, oder du willst irgendwelche
Sound-Geschichten machen, wo du Zugriff auf die Windows-Sachen brauchst, also du brauchst
für vieles heutzutage absolut keine System-Calls und Browser wird ausreichen, aber gerade
für die Sachen, wo man sagt man möchte native was entwickeln, die brauchen in der Regel
das halt auch und dann ist halt für'n Arsch.
Ja, Filesystem-Access, richtig ordentlicher Filesystem-Access, ja, wie soll das Sebaro
seine Anime-Collections gescheit verwalten mit ner Browser-App, wenn er 20TB lokal im
Filesystem liegen hat. Ja, du kannst, du musst dafür aber von Hand anfordern beziehungsweise
der User muss in den öffnen Dialog klicken und sowas. Ist ja auch klar, weil sonst könnt
ja jede Website einfach deine Festplatte einlesen.
Ja, Flutter ist Poggers, ich hoffe, dass Flutter auf dem Desktop noch besser supportet wird.
Aktuell gibt es glaub ich noch nicht mal nen Browser, also kein Browser-Gadget für Flutter
auf dem Desktop und auch keine Möglichkeit irgendwelche OpenGL oder DirectX Sachen rein
zu rendern, womit man zum Beispiel schon mal keinen Videoplayer machen kann. Also VLC
im Flutter würde nicht funktionieren aktuell. Ja, das gibt's meistens aber im Browser,
im Browser hast du ja mittlerweile sogar USB-Zugriff, wenn du nen aktuellen Browser hast. Alter,
was geht denn mit der Musik grade ab? 1KS, jetzt haben wir gut. Alter, das ist übertrieben
hektisch. Ja. Ja, was aber nix dran ändert, das macht ja nur den Download kleiner. Ram
Verbrauch und so ist immer noch das gleiche. Also für jedes neue Tab. Vielleicht beim ersten
Tab nicht, weil Windows das schon vorlädt, aber für die weiteren Tabs schon. Ja, das
ist das, das ist richtig. Also Native Anwendung Entwickel ist Absolut Paints-Champ aktuell.
Welchen Anbieter würdest du für E-Mail mit eigenem Domain empfehlen? Keine Ahnung. Ich
verwende so gut wie keine Mails mehr, außer für YouTube-Business-Stells. Mailbox Org.
Ja, ja, das liegt hauptsächlich daran, weil's Microsoft seit 15 Jahren verkackt hat, ein
ordentliches UI-Framework rauszubringen. Bei Apple ist das kein Ding. Guckt mal rüber
zu Apple. Die kriegen das gebacken. So, dann gucken wir mal weiter. Was haben wir denn
hier noch Schönes? Wir gucken uns jetzt, wir gucken uns jetzt das Gaming on Linux an.
Nicht Gaming on Linus, Linus Gaming on Linux. So, Rob. Und ich kann jetzt schon sagen, ich
kann das Video nicht, aber ich kann jetzt schon sagen, das wird eine Reihenfall. Wenn's
ich grad Super-Tux-Card ist. Dann nicht. Ja.
Ach, nee.
Okay, das Game ist schon wieder so broken, dass ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass es vielleicht
sogar läuft. Aber realistisch betrachtet keine Chance, gerade wegen der Anti-Cheat-Geschichte.
Wo ist der Freak, der ist schon für den Zap.
Viele können's launchen, aber werden instant gekickt. Ja, das wird wegen Anti-Cheat sein.
Anti-Cheat erkennt, was weiß ich, Spiel wird in VM oder sonst was gestartet. Das mit Anti-Cheat
ist aber meistens nur ein Vorwand. Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube ja und nein. Klar ist das ein gutes
so Catch-All-Argument zu sagen, ja, Anti-Cheat, das geht nicht. Aber auf der anderen Seite,
du hast halt unter Linus auch deutlich mehr Möglichkeiten. Und wenn du quasi in Anti-Cheat
erlaubst, dass du, wie soll ich es nennen, dass du ein Game quasi in einer gut debugbaren
Eventuell sogar VM-Umgebung ausführst, wo du das viel besser beobachten kannst, viel
besser analysieren kannst, eventuell sogar irgendwelche Systemaufrufe austauschen kannst
durch eigene Sachen, um besser zu analysieren, was es macht. Da kann ich auch verstehen,
dass man das Anti-Cheat technisch nicht will. Also... Ja, ja, das gibt's auch unter Windows,
das ist richtig. Aber sobald die Dinger was erkennen, dass da irgendwas manipuliert ist,
dann schmeißen sie dich raus. Ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch daran, wo ich mal versucht
habe, Modern Warfare dazu zu überreden, könnt ihr euch noch an den Soundbug von Modern Warfare
erinnern, dass es am Anfang, wenn du es gestartet hast, immer maximale Lautstärke gegangen ist.
So, und wir haben dazu was programmiert. Was im Hintergrund geguckt hat, wird Modern Warfare
gelauncht. Wenn Modern Warfare gelauncht wird, dann geh über die Mixer-AP von Windows und
stell den Sound von Modern Warfare runter. Und was ist passiert? Das Ding wurde vom Anti-Cheat
als Cheat erkannt und hat das Spiel immer geschlossen direkt. So, und das gibt es unter
Windows, natürlich. Aber die schmeißen dich raus, wenn sie es erkennen. Und dementsprechend
ist Wine ja quasi ein komplett, wenn du so willst, ein kompletterer Hook, als du jemals
unter Windows machen könntest. Und das erkennen sie und schmeißen dich raus. Das kann ich
schon verstehen, dass man das nicht will. Ja, hab ich direkt geklickt. Aber ich wurde nicht
gebannt wenigstens, ja. Das ist alles so ein Problem. Das ist so ein, auf der einen Seite,
du brauchst Anti-Cheat. Du kommst um Anti-Cheat nicht drumherum, aber es ist halt so ein Wettrennen
zwischen Cheatern und Anti-Cheat und mittlerweile halt auch so komischen Interessen wie, ach
ja, ich baue mal einen Bitcoin-Miner ein in meinen Anti-Cheat. Oder ich bin Cristiano
Ronaldo und meine Monero auf meiner Webseite, falls ich da noch irgendjemand dran erinnern
kann. Wobei der Typ davon garantiert nichts wusste. Ich glaube nicht, dass Cristiano
Ronaldo so der krasse Hacker-Man ist in seiner Freizeit, der sich mit seinem JavaScript auf
der Webseite beschäftigt. Aber ja, die Webseite von Cristiano Ronaldo hatte mal einen Monero-Miner.
Top Monero war es. Cristiano betreibt Kripto-Meinung auf Kosten, genau. Ah, da haben wir ein Kommando
dazu, genau. Das machen sie garantiert auch schon. Das geilste an Cheating, was ich in
letzter Zeit gesehen habe ist, und das ist auch so fast nicht detectbar, das ist eine
Mischung aus Microcontroller für die Maus und Fake-Netzwerkkarte für den PCI-Express-Slot.
Also das funktioniert folgendermaßen. Du baust dir in deinem PCI-Express-Slot eine
Netzwerkkarte ein. Die meldet sich im PCI-System als Netzwerkkarte und es wird dementsprechend
auch Windows-Kernel-technisch was geladen. Das heißt, du installierst irgendeinen Kernel-Driver
für die Netzwerkkarte und alles ist gut. Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass das gar keine
Netzwerkkarte ist, das ist eine Fake-Netzwerkkarte, die den Windows-Driver dazu verwendet, auf
den kompletten, oder so weit wie möglich, also ohne, dass es ein Anti-Cheat gescheit
erkennen könnte, auf den Arbeitsspeicher zuzugreifen. Unter anderem auch auf den Arbeitsspeicher,
wo dann dein Spiel läuft. Ja, das war übrigens das erste, was ich jetzt erzähle gab es zuerst
für Valorant tatsächlich. Also du baust eine Fake-Netzwerkkarte ein und die Netzwerkkarte
ist gar keine Netzwerkkarte, sondern greift auf den RAM von Spielen über PCI-Express
zu und dann hast du an der Maus einen Micro-Controller, der für dich die Maus etwas besser führt,
nennen wir es mal so. Also du benutzt die Maus schon noch komplett automatisch, aber
wenn du zum Beispiel über den Kopf fährst vom Gegner, headshott er dann automatisch.
Und das geht halt nur aus der Kombination, RAM auslesen über PCI-Express und Schüsse
triggern mit Micro-Controller für die Maus. Also das ist mittlerweile sehr, sehr advanced
und also diese Mausgeschichte ist nicht detectbar, wie auch, wie soll ein automatischer Klick
von der Maus detectbar sein, das ist ja nichts, was du irgendwie im Windows aus erkennen
könntest. Also wenigstens nicht direkt detectbar, über Statistik und so reden wir jetzt gar
nicht, wenn du 99% Headshots hast, wohingegen Pros nur auf 20 kommen, ist klar, dass du
cheatest. Und die Netzwerkkarte, die Fake-Netzwerkkarte kannst du auch nur schlecht erkennen, weil
es ist ja, sag mal so, es wäre utopisch davon auszugehen, dass du eine Hardware-Datenbank
haben kannst, mit jeglicher erlaubten Hardware. Ich habe dann Pop-Schutz drauf, das Problem
ist nur, dass es halt ein bisschen suckt. Aber ich glaube, das liegt manchmal auch,
wenn ich hier, das da, das ist der Reißverschluss vom Pulli. Ja, was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Ich glaube, theoretisch also für besseren, wie sagt man so, so, so Production Value,
ich müsste tatsächlich auf ein ordentliches Mikrofon umsteigen. So ein richtiges Mikrofon
zum reinreden und nicht Headset. Ja, zumindest, was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Ja, die Netzwerkkarte
ist auch nicht wirklich gut zu erkennen, weil du kannst ja sowohl Mac als auch PCIe, ID
und alles Mögliche kannst du ja ändern. Also, die muss ja heute nicht die gleiche ID haben
wie morgen. Zumal ja da auch ein Controller drauf ist, dass sich das System nach einem
Reboot einfach mit einem anderen, mit anderen ID meldet. Also das ist schwierig zu erkennen
und es ist utopisch, dass du eine Hardware-Datenbank im Anti-Cheat hast oder eine autorisierte
Datenbank, die alle nur erdenkliche Hardware abdeckt. Das kannst du machen für Pro Tournaments,
das geht, wenn du im Vorfeld weißt, welche Hardware die Leute haben, welche Monitore
die verwenden, welche Mäuse die verwenden. Okay, aber nicht für die breite Masse. Äh,
Headminister, wenn du ein gutes hast, schick mir mal was, was ein Pop-Schutz fürs Headset
was taugt. Ich hab einen drauf, der standardmäßig mitgeliefert ist, aber der ist halt anscheinend
nicht so geil. Äh, du kannst die jetzt schon privat benutzen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir
es todo.caqw.services. Ach ne, oh, service unavailable, null. Aber ganz ehrlich, die willst
du nicht privat benutzen. Das ist eine to-do-Listen-App, die ich zum Üben bastel. Nichts, was man
irgendwie productionmäßig verwenden sollte. So, jetzt gucken wir mal weiter. Linux, äh,
Linux, Linux Gaming Challenge. Sack, ich, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das,
das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das, das,
So was ist richtig pock.
So nen Puschel bräuchte ich.
Das da ist besser als das da.
Umso luftiger das ganze ist, umso besser.
Benutz ne Socke.
Wie soll ich ne Socke über mein Headset Mikrofon ziehen?
Schöne Anleitung zum selber Bauen?
Aus nem Schwamm.
In der groben Form zurecht.
Muss man jetzt so bisschen rumschnibbeln.
Schnibbeln?
Aus nem Schwamm.
Pie-Pad, Alter.
Das ist ungefähr erstmal ne grobe Form und da soll jetzt das Mikro hier natürlich reingesteckt
werden.
Dafür machen wir uns hier erstmal ein Loch.
Voll steckt das Mikrofon rein.
Ich mein schön ist das nicht, aber das ist wahrscheinlich besser als die meisten Pop-Schutze,
die du so kaufen kannst.
Pop-Schutze?
Ja, das ist zwar ein bisschen groß, ein bisschen viel, ja, aber die Pop-Schutze, die du dir
kaufen kannst fürs Headset, die sind zu dünn, das ist viel besser hier.
Exzellent, exzellent, höhere Quali gibt's da nicht.
Das ist richtig nice, sowas baue ich mir Leute, sowas baue ich mir.
Nächster Stream, On-Stream, können wir, wir können sogar On-Stream, Leute wir machen
das On-Stream, wir machen das On-Stream.
Das ist kein Problem, da nimmst du einfach ein Edding und meist den blauen Schwamm, schwarz
ab.
Ach Quatsch, ich nehme auch einen blauen Schwamm.
Das ist eine gute Idee, gucken wir mal, ob es da auch gescheite vielleicht schon fertig
bei Amazon gibt, weil das sind die Billigdinger, die sacken richtig, so einen habe ich auch,
das ist Müll.
Hört sich halt dumm an.
Die hier sehen schon ein bisschen besser aus, die sind ein bisschen dicker, sowas da, sowas
bräuchte man für ein Headset, wobei man keine Ahnung hat ob das für ein Headset geht.
Sowas da, so ein Ding habe ich auch für mein, für mein normales Mikro, wo ich die Videos
mit aufnehme.
Ja Wind, Wind und na Mund haben ist ja, ist ja ähnlich, gerade wenn man pp pp pp macht.
Ja diese Puscheldinger sind Pog, Poggers, Poggers sind die, gibt GoPro Aufkleber, klappt
super.
Hä wie GoPro Aufkleber, Hä, GoPro, Hallo, GoPro Aufkleber,
Hell, What, Achso Pop Schutz, ich piepel, Pop Schutz, Aha, ja das ist ja sowas.
Kannst du den Headset Mik biegen, ja, ja kann ich, ich habe das schon so platziert, dass
ich normalerweise nicht direkt rein mache, aber das ist schwierig, das so gut hin zu
bekommen, dass es sich noch gut anhört und weit genug weg ist.
Also ich habe ja das hier, war ja, äh 300 nicht 500, lul und da ist ja so ein Pop Schutz
drauf, aber das sackt halt einfach.
Der Scheiß ist nicht billig gewesen, ich mache das mit dem Schwamm, ohne Scheiß Leute,
das mit dem Schwamm klingt nach einer richtig geilen Idee.
Na gut, also ich muss sagen von Headset Mikros an sich ist das mit das beste Headset Mikro
was es gibt, aber ein ordentliches nicht Headset Mikro schlägt das halt locker.
Ganz ehrlich, ich habe auch zumindest zwei ältere Modmix und da finde ich das qualitativ
deutlich besser als die Modmix.
So, jetzt gucken wir aber erstmal das Video fertig hier, was ist es eigentlich mit den
ganzen, mit den ganzen Anime-Avataren hier, guckt euch das mal an.
Headset hat jemand eine Empfehlung für eine CPU, für ein 24 Homesäuber, sollte ausreichend
für Docker insgesamt Stromspann sein?
Ja, also ausreichend für Docker ist ja, ist ja sehr nichts sagend, weil du kannst Docker
auf dem größten und kleinsten Linux System betreiben, was du dir vorstellst.
Docker an sich hat ja keinen Overhead in dem Sinn.
Ob du jetzt einen Prozess startest oder einen Prozess in einem Container startest, macht
eigentlich keinen Unterschied.
Die Frage ist, was willst du im Container laufen lassen?
Also überall da wo Linux läuft mit einem Kernel neu genug für Container kannst du
auch Container starten.
Denn Container ist ja nichts weiteres als ein weiterer Prozess mit ein bisschen Sandbox
drum herum.
Also was ich habe ist, was Gigabyte, MSI, ne, SROG war es ne, SROG, Intel, Low Power,
Sock.
Hier, ich hab sowas in der Richtung.
Ich hab sowas in der Richtung, die gibt's in verschiedenen, in verschiedenen Varianten.
Die kann ich dir empfehlen, da, achja, guck mal hier, was ein paar Asos da los, bei SROG,
Set Cookie, Name, Value, EXP, Set Time, da war der Webdesigner wieder am Start.
Rechnen die da von Hand die Zeit für einen Monat oder so?
30 Tage mal 24 Stunden mal 60, 60 Minuten mal 60 Sekunden, die Millisekunden, rechnen
die hier die Millisekunden für einen Monat aus oder was ist das?
Oje, das ist noch ASP, das alte.NET ASP ist das, nicht ASP.NET Core, das ist oldschool.
SOS, ja, keine Ahnung, was die da machen, der sieht auch allgemein nicht so vertrauenswürdig
aus hier, ja, aber diese Sachen finde ich nicht schlecht, damit reißt du wirklich keine
Bäume aus, aber du willst ja wahrscheinlich auch nichts Großartiges machen.
Die sind wirklich nicht verkehrt.
Kannst dir zum Beispiel, das ist wenn ich ans Mikrofon komme, ich glaube das ist nicht
so wild, kannst dir zum Beispiel sowas hier kaufen oder auch noch was Altes mit ein bisschen
längeren PC Express Slot und das ist wirklich nice, da, wie gesagt, da habe ich auch meine
Kiste mit laufen, du kommst auf unter 10 Watt Eidl, wenn du Stromspargeschichten einschaltest.
Wohlgemerkt, für das Board, für das Board mit einer SSD dran und ohne CPU-Auslastung,
dann hast du unter 10 Watt Eidl, wenn du deine Festplatte dran machst oder so, die läuft,
dann ist natürlich mehr.
Alles klar, Netzteil, ich habe eine Pico-USV dran mit, ne, wie heißt das Ding, nicht USB,
Pico Power Supply, sowas da, Pico PSU, PSU, so ein Ding hatte ich noch rumliegen.
Das ist im Prinzip ein ATX-Stecker mit Netzteileingang auf der einen Seite, also steckst das hier
ins Mainboard und auf der anderen Seite steckst du es in ein normales, ich glaube 12 Volt
Netzteil.
Also hier, hier, man erkennt das nicht richtig, hier, genau, also das steckst du ins Mainboard
und hier stöpselst du ein explikates 12 Volt Netzteil dran.
Genauso habe ich das auch.
Sieht sus aus, ist es aber netz, jetzt gucken wir aber endlich mal, das wird.
A lot of games to a satisfactory level that by the time I was ready, everyone else was
just done gaming for the night and as a lot of my friends like to just try random games
out for fun, this actually happened a lot.
Our goal is not to spread FUD about the state of Linux gaming though, so it's time to get
specific about some of our less good.
FUD, das ist so eines der, der werbesich haben Kollegen auf der Arbeit, der verwende das
immer gerne.
FUD ist Fear, ich kriege die Abkürzung gar nicht mehr zusammen, Fear and Uncertainty,
ich weiß nicht mehr für was FUD für eine Abkürzung ist, aber wir haben einen auf
der Arbeit, der verwende das für so ziemlich alles als Abkürzung.
Ja, also mit SSD ist, wenn die SSD Eidl ist, verbraucht ihr auch kaum was.
Das werden die aber garantiert nicht schaffen, lul.
Ja, ja, das kommt noch dabei, du hast ja mittlerweile mindestens 5 Launcher, die du installiert
haben musst, Pupke, läuft Pupke unter Linux, New World, ok, ok, New World Massive muss
man sagen, New World ist auf dem besten Weg in die Bedeutungslosigkeit.
Super Tox, nein, Super Tox Card, das einzig wahre Linux Game.
Ja es war Anchor One.
ja wenn sie wollen ich wollte gerade sagen die meisten davon dürften funktionieren
bei rust hätte ich jetzt ein bisschen bedenken gemacht wobei ich glaube cheating in rust ist
einfach so ein ding was die mittlerweile hinnehmen oder ich glaube die haben in rust die entwickler
habs aufgegeben cheater zu bekämpfen zero actual effort and interestingly enough dota 2
and csgo both had completely game breaking problems that weren't isolated to my system during the
challenge they seem to be solved now but it goes to show that just like with windows because a piece
of software was made for it doesn't mean it's actually going to be perfect i didn't have any
issues running csgo even got me some kills boys but the sweet kennisch auf significantly more stutters
than i'm used to seeing on this class of hardware that could be an nvidia driver issue or it could
be something else also was ist das schon wieder für eine schrift benutzt man wirklich sein desktop
so mit dieser schrift hat but for me it worked well enough that i didn't feel like digging any
further into that rabbit hole not when i could be digging for a sweet hoodie like this one on
lttstore.com instead the next tier is windows native games that valve officially lists as
linux capable via steam play but before we go any further i just want to say massive respect to
the incredible teams who have worked tirelessly to make running windows games on linux possible
valves proton compatibility layer is amazing it's worked from wine which has been multiple decades
in the making with about half of its source code written by volunteers that's freaking wild and of
course honorable mentions all around for the dedicated communities that maintain tools like
lutris which automates hacky workarounds for newbies and proton db which serves as both a
troubleshooting resource and a reference for which games work so you won't have to waste your money
on a bad experience with all of that said in spite of all of that work we're honestly just not there
yet and we're mere months for ich kann mich auf wine hq war das wo man früher geguckt hat ob die
sachen laufen oder nicht da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern dass damals einträge auf silber
standen und silber einfach nur bedeutet hat lässt sich installieren und starten da hattest du dann
software drinne so nach oder spiele drin so nach dem motto installs and launches gameplay
doesn't work silber naja also bei silber würde ich eigentlich von ausgehen man kann das spiel
komplett spielen hat aber probleme zwischendurch nicht nur installiert und startet lutris und
proton irgendwie verwandt nein lutris ist quasi so ein bisschen bisschen schöner installer für
sachen und proton ist wie soll man das jetzt schön überschreiben ein emulation ein emulation slayer
der kein emulation slayer ist für übersetzung auf von von top open gl auf direkt x oder irgendwie
sowas in der richtung nee moment das war was anderes nee proton ist da weinfork also quasi
die nachgebaute windows api linux die auf linux funktionen map launch of the steam deck when
100 percent compatibility is supposedly coming which as of writing this ja ja die erzählen
viel ja ist klar in zwei monaten haben 100 prozent kompatibilität alles klar alles klar wer glaubt
es auch noch und bettel viel 2042 wird für yes to come supported alles klar also du maternal
reported great performance on my system over 200 frames per second using the included tool
i'm kind of reminded of the issues that we used to see an old sli configurations where the actual
perceived animation smoothness is substantially less than what the benchmark seems to suggest it
should be again i thought maybe this is an issue with my proprietary nvidia driver maybe it's at a
date but manjaro begged to differ apparently i am up to date so your mileage may vary another
problem that's been a foreign in the side of the linux by the way here's is anti-cheat yeah das
kannst du knicken das kannst du knicken es sei denn die machen damit und wie gesagt wie ich wie ich
eben schon erzählen habe ich kann es verstehen wenn sie nicht mitmachen run totally fine but
while theoretically enabling battle i anti-cheat in rainbow 6 siege is as simple as ubisoft reaching
out doing a little bit of kajiggering and off we go because battle i has supposedly supported linux
for ages ubisoft hasn't done that yet why well because natively supporting linux is seen by some
developers as a somewhat brutal experience ben gaullis has a rather enlightening thread
about this on twitter he goes on to explain that while linux gamers were a very vocal part
community they accounted for less than 0.1 percent of sales yet they generated more than 20
percent of auto reported crashes and support tickets he also stated that near the end of his time
there nearly 100 percent of tickets were still linux related despite linux receiving the majority
of the engineering effort meaning the company likely spent hundreds of thousands of dollars
supporting a community that made them a few hundred in sales revenue and this isn't the only
version story and every time problems like these happen it's just more ammo for developers that
would rather spend a lot of money working on linux versions of their products i believe
weiss halt auch so eine sache ist wenn man das von anfang an in der entwicklung vorhat
und es auch regelmäßig testet und es nicht irgendwie den kickstarter stretch goal ist
was man am ende noch irgendwie versucht rein zu zu wursten dann hast du da wahrscheinlich
genauso viele und genauso wenige probleme wie unter windows man muss es halt von anfang an
vorhaben
auftrag 2334 sagt ist es nicht einfacher sich eine zweite maschine mit windows zu holen
als ich mit kompatibilitätsproblemen zu beschäftigen ja ist einfacher ist es garantiert noch besser
ist es du machst so wie ich du nimmst windows auf deinem host system wo du spielen willst und du
hast auf dem zweiten desktop einfache linux vm offen mit der du alles machen kannst was du so
machen willst weil grafik performance ist ja in der vm nicht das problem weil du willst ja nicht
in der vm spielen und ansonsten hast du windows und wenn du was machen willst was du gerne unter
linux machst zum beispiel sachen programmieren switchte rüber in die linux vm und benutzt
linux muss jetzt mal kurz warten bis das ding gestartet ist was ziemlich lahm ist gerade die
meisten games dürfen unreal und unity sein und da kannst du ohne probleme fertiges linux binary
raushauen das geht schon musst aber halt testen während deinem entwicklungsprozess permanent ob
das funktioniert und muss von anfang an planen und dann geht das auch so also so mache ich das hier
linux einfach auf dem zweiten desktop haben und dann sagen ok wir programmieren jetzt was rüber
switching auf linux auf geht's überhaupt kein problem es ist einfacher linux unter windows zu
virtualisieren als windows unter linux das kommt dann noch dabei dass es am endeffekt sich nicht
wirklich lohnt aber wenn du es von anfang an vor hast ist es glaube ich kein problem ist es so kann
ich weiß ich nichts kann ich nichts zu sagen ich hätte jetzt gedacht dass es wenig an problemen ist
das ist immer wieder problem z plus plus ja das ist mir letztendlich egal wenn
windows lizent kostet 7 euro 50 und das habe ich schon aufgegeben da irgendwann klar ich habe auch
so ein paar prinzipien was ich nicht machen will aber mittlerweile gerade hier entwicklungstechnik
und software ich verwende das was am einfachsten ist was am besten funktioniert ich spiele unter
windows und programmieren bastel unter linux fertig aus genau oder wsl 2 wenn man keine vm will ich
benutze vor immer workstation ne ne ne ne schön wäre es wenn das so einfach ist so einfach ist
es leider nicht wenn du nämlich davor also du hast dann mehrere probleme deswegen sage ich ja
es ist einfacher als als es einfacher windows unter linux zu virtuell ist nein das funktioniert
nicht weißt du ich habe das noch nie ausprobiert du kannst das durchreichen aber hast du ganz andere
probleme wie steuerst du deine vm schließt du die maus direkt an machst du pci machst du nicht nur
pci passt zu machst du auch usb passt zu wie bedienst du das schließt so einen zweiten monitor
an schaltest du dann den monitor immer um dsd da geht schon weiter dann hast du die maus an die
vm weitergegeben und wir verwenden wie bedienst du dann deinen host oder brauchst du eine zweite
maus dafür das ist halt einfach kacke dass ich weiß dass das technisch möglich ist und vielleicht
soll ich da jetzt nicht so gedriggert drauf reagieren ich weiß dass das technisch möglich
ist aber es ist kommt es ist alles andere als komfortabel ich weiß dass das geht und ich weiß
auch dass das möglich ist und gut läuft aber es ist nicht vergleichbar mit ich switch auf
den zweiten desktop rüber und habe eine funktionsfähiges linux das ist das ist nicht
so nicht also es ist es hört sich einfacher an als es in der praktischen anwendung dann ist
ich weiß du hast dann so sachen wie wie ist das looking class dass du das wiederum rüber
spiegeln kannst das ist in der theorie vielleicht nicht schlecht aber in der praxis in der anwendung
ist das ist das nicht dabei ist als letzter schluss das kommt auch noch dabei dass du bei
einigen konsumer mainboards noch das problem hast dass du gar nicht einfach nur einzelne
geräte durchreichen kann sondern alles was an diesem pizzi express switch hängt solche
dinger ich weiß ich weiß wir haben uns das ja sogar schon mal angeguckt wie ich den switch
auf den zweiten desktop mache ich drücke ich drücke kontrol windows tasten rechter
feil und dann bin ich in der vm oder ich drücke kontrol windows linker feilen mit viel auf
dem desktop ja da muss ich mal zeigen wie gut das wirklich ist am endeffekt da bin ich
auch mal gespannt darauf aktuell schreckt mich ab dass du noch windows 11 brauchst wenn
aus hat schon seit jahre seit winos 10 hast du mit den desktops und hier unten dafür
ist der knopf noch da als sie noch nicht verwendet hast da bin ich auch mal gespannt
drauf dass mit wsl g läuft aber ich könnte mir vorstellen dass ich müsste das mal regelmäßiger
verwenden dass du immer noch probleme hast weil keine ahnung wie ist es zum beispiel
mit nfs mountain wie ist es mit nfs mountain bsl tut das gescheit mit lab ja gut es ist
eine vm das sollte eigentlich mittlerweile gehen also ich müsste mal wsl wenn ich mal
bin aus elf irgendwann hab werde ich das werde ich das öfters auch mal verwenden damit aber
ich könnte wetten es gibt halt gerade so sachen wie nfs mountain oder irgendwelche sachen gibt
es halt problemchen also mit wsl 1 ging es auf gar keinen fall mit wsl 2 jetzt in der
vm geht es wahrscheinlich aber so sachen in dieser richtung wirst du immer öfters mal
haben ja gut vm synchronisieren du meinst jetzt das image file das habe ich noch nicht
ausprobiert den inhalt halt wobei image fall synchronisieren wird auch funktionieren aber
habe ich darf ich mir noch keine genannten zugemacht also ich könnte wetten wenn ich
das wirklich tagtäglich verwende ich finde innerhalb des ersten monats bestimmt fünf
dinger die mich so abfacken die nicht richtig funktionieren naja schauen wir mal gucken
wir mal das video fertig
ich meine es ist jetzt nicht so als dass ich windows wirklich feier oder so ihr wisst
es geht mir auch auf den sack aber es ist nur mal was was viele leute gerne machen dass
die spiele spielen und das geht um am besten unter windows da hat er nicht unrecht das
dumme ist nur fragmentation ja du hast kde du hast gnome du hast zig andere bisschen
mehr niche desktop anwendung was so sachen wie i3 was gar kein richtiger desktop eigentlich
ist die sache ist die es gibt aus meiner sicht nichts was sich da irgendwie als sinnvoller
standard eignen würde gnome hat sich ja so ein bisschen als standard etabliert also
die meisten sachen dürften heutzutage auf gnome sein aber gnome hat auch komische komische
design dinger also zum beispiel dass sie jetzt angefangen haben zu sagen tray icons sind
bloated braucht man nicht mehr jetzt ja schön wenn das desktop team das entscheidet das
erinnert mich ein bisschen an die windows taskleiste die in windows 11 gesagt haben nö wir erlauben
das nicht mehr dass sachen in der taskleiste entgruppiert werden die müssten jetzt nur
noch gruppiert sein gibt es das gibt es ab windows 11 nicht also was ihr hier seht dass
ich für meine beiden chromium fenster zwei icons hier unten haben gibt es ab windows
11 nicht mehr das ist dann ein icon wo ich dann drüber gehen muss dann oben drauf klicken
was ich was ein scheiß was soll das also mir fällt jetzt auch unter linux nichts ein was
ich da großartig eignen würde als standard
außerdem gefällt mir davon auch nichts mir gefällt weder gnome noch gefällt mir kde
noch gefällt mir xfc das ist noch das am erträglichsten weil es relativ simpel und
lightweight ist weder gefällt mir maids noch cinnamon noch botschi noch sonst mir gefallen
die ganzen linux desktops nicht
lx qt was das sonst noch alles gibt das einzige was mir gefällt ist i3 und dann mit i3 gaps
wobei das kannst ja nicht als desktop umgebung verwendet bezeichnen i3 i3 hat halt noch nicht
mal ein desktop das hat einen hintergrund bild
ach so stimmt stimmt leute doch doch eine sache gefällt mir
besser desktop guckt euch an besser desktop chat also das das das top glaube ich sonst
keiner mehr
warum ich weiß gar nicht mehr warum ich glaube weil der chat das irgendwann mal sehen
wollte
ansonsten könnte ich mich könnte ich mir auch nicht erklären warum wir das gemacht
haben
ok wir gucken jetzt aber jetzt wirklich das video erstmal fertig
das ist nicht webbuntu das ist mobuntu webbuntu gibt es glaube ich gar nicht
das beste ist dass die die webseite wo man sich diesen skin runterladen kann sieht auch
wahnsinnig vertrauenserweckend aus
findet ihr nicht auch dass man sich von dort nen skin runterladen will
da hätte ich eher bedenken dass ich mir einen krypto meiner einfange wenn ich mir hier irgendwas
runter lade
hat sogar ein blog ich hab angst in den blog rein zu gucken
wer weiß ob da irgendwelche tost bilder kommen hast du was von ubuntu gehört nein
wird mich aber auch nicht wundern wenn es das gibt
so jetzt gucken wir wirklich das video endlich fertig meine güte ich krieg da gar nichts
auf die reihe heute
ja das verstehe ich bei linus
das verstehe ich bei linus auch nicht wieder so ein riesen monitor verwenden kann man hat
das letzte ja mal letztes mal ja gesehen das jetzt vor den monitors passiert links unten
was und er sieht nicht was links unten passiert weil er rechts oben hinguckt
bcm hell
zu finden, dass die Forged Alliance Forever Launcher, die auf Linux gearbeitet hat,
beinahe hoffnungslos ausgedreht war oder nicht verwendbar war für mein besonderes Distro.
Ich blamiere die Devs nicht, wirklich, nichts anderes als Liebe für euch.
Aber Linux-Gamer und mehrfach die Linux-Kommunikation müssen verstehen,
dass bis die Bedürfnisse der Supporting von Linux deutlich reduziert werden,
wird das immer ein Problem sein.
Wir haben eigentlich live-streamt, um durch die Forged Alliance-Issues auf Floatplane zu arbeiten,
um euch zu abonnieren.
Es gab mehr als ein paar Kommentare im Chat, die uns kritisiert haben, um...
Wo haben die... Wo haben die live-streamt?
...Issues auf Floatplane zu abonnieren, übrigens.
Hä?
Was sind das für Dinge? Wozu braucht man das?
Es gab mehr als ein paar Kommentare im Chat, die uns kritisiert haben, um in diesem Spiel zu spielen,
weil es älter ist, es ist nur ein krasse Java-Spiel, es ist obscurer, oder weil es nicht fair zu Linux ist.
Ey, diese Antworten triggern mich auch immer.
Die Leute gehen mir so auf den Sack.
Wenn irgendjemand... Es ist egal, was, es muss doch nicht mal was zu spielen und Linux sein.
Wenn irgendjemand eine sinnvolle Frage stellt, dass man dann als Antwort bekommt,
ja, warum möchte man das denn machen?
Und ach, spiel doch lieber was anderes.
Nee, nee, du musst das so machen und das ist eh nicht der richtige Ansatz.
Also ich mach das so und so und das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Typisches Forum-Dünnschiss.
Das ist noch nicht mal Stackoverflow-Style, das ist microcontroller.net-Forum-Style.
Die haben's mir eh angetan.
Was haben wir hier für Copy-Pasta, was?
Ich hab wirklich nichts geschrieben, was irgendjemand provoziert, was?
Hä?
Das ist ne Copy-Pasta, oder?
Ansonsten erkenne ich nicht den Zusatz.
Ansonsten erkenne ich nicht den Zusammenhang.
Zum Stream oder zum Chat.
Das ist bestimmt ne Copy-Pasta.
Also Discord, oder?
Und das hat mir echt die Augen geöffnet, warum so viele Leute auf Konsolen spielen.
Das sag ich ja auch seit Jahren schon, deswegen ist Konsole die Casual-Plattform.
Fertig.
Deswegen mögen die Konsolen.
Doch, Linux sackt fürs Spielen.
Ist einfach so.
Man muss es gar nicht schön umschreiben, dass sich die Linux-Fans nicht gedriggert fühlen.
Ich verdiene mein Geld damit.
Ich beschäftige mich viele Stunden und habe mich Jahre mit Linux beschäftigt.
Ich habe das auch schon alles hinter mir.
Inklusive GPU-Pass-Through habe ich alles schon gemacht.
Linux sackt fürs Spielen.
Auch zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt noch.
Linux allgemein sackt nicht.
Sonst hätte ich keine Linux-VM permanent offen auf dem zweiten Desktop.
Es war phänomenal. Ich fühlte mich wie der König.
Aber dann die nächsten 45 Minuten...
Okay, warum ist die Multiplayer nicht verbunden?
Und wenn du spielen willst, kannst du einfach auf Windows spielen.
Oder meinen Videoschnittgedöns machen unter Windows, oder was auch immer.
Oder Hardware-decoded-Videos im Browser gucken.
Was hat dein PC für Specs?
Ich hab einen 8700K, 32G RAM glaube ich mittlerweile.
Ich bin mir immer nicht sicher was es ist, 16?
32G RAM, weil es geht, nicht dass man das wirklich bräuchte.
Und ordentlich SSD-Speicher.
Funktioniert Docker mittlerweile einigermaßen in einer VM?
Docker hat schon immer in VMs funktioniert.
Warum sollte Docker nicht in einer VM funktionieren?
Ein Programm normal starten oder ein Programm im Container starten,
ist überhaupt kein Unterschied.
Nein, das war auch performanstechnisch nicht mau.
Was du meinst ist, was performanstechnisch mau ist,
ist nested-Virtualisierung.
Wenn du KVM oder VirtualBox oder VMware Workstation oder sowas,
wenn du irgendwas virtualisiert hast, in einer VM startest,
dann geht das entweder gar nicht,
wenn du die Option dafür nicht aktiviert hast,
und wenn du die Option dafür aktiviert hast,
dann ist es nested-virtualisiert teilweise ziemlich langsam.
Also nested-Virtualisierung ist doof,
Docker ist ja keine Virtualisierung,
und dementsprechend überhaupt kein Problem
und ging schon immer in einer VM.
Läuft deine VM lokal oder auf allem?
So, das läuft lokal.
Hier, guck da, VMware Workstation, fertig.
VMware Workstation, Fullscreen auf dem zweiten Desktop.
Es geht, es geht, aber es ist performanstechnisch nicht dabei,
ist als letzter Schluss.
Ja, natürlich ist VirtualBox lahm,
VirtualBox ist ja auch kein Container.
VirtualBox ist ja auch voll Virtualisierung.
Das ist langsam, das ist nested-Virtualisierung.
Nested-Virtualisierung ist langsam,
Docker und sonstige Sachen ist nichts mit Virtualisierung.
Virtualisierung in Virtualisierung kann sehr lahm sein,
Docker ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Weil, wie gesagt, ob du einen Prozess so startest,
also ob ich jetzt Echo 1, 2, 3 mache so,
na gut, Echo ist ein dummes Beispiel,
weil das ist Shell-Build-in, aber kommt auch gleich heraus.
Also ob ich jetzt Echo 1, 2, 3 so auf der Konsole mache,
oder ob ich Docker run Echo 1, 2, 3 mache,
ist performanstechnisch kaum nennenswerter Overhead.
Warum das am Anfang erst einmal dauert,
ist, weil unten drunter noch ein extra Image
quasi gestartet werden muss.
Aber wenn das läuft, ist es überhaupt kein Ding.
Also ein Prozess in einer Sandbox starten
oder ein Prozess so starten, macht kaum einen Unterschied.
Doch, Docker hat nichts mit Virtualisierung zu tun.
Docker, also der Unterschied zwischen Echo 1, 2, 3 auf der Konsole machen
oder sagen wir mal, sagen wir mal nicht Echo 1, 2, 3,
einen Web-Server zu starten auf Port 666,
hier bei mir im Host, ach so, ja,
oder in einem Docker-Container ist kein wirklicher Unterschied.
Der einzige Unterschied ist, dass jeder Prozess direkt gestartet wird
und wenn du das in einem Container startest,
dann ist noch, da ist noch eine Sandbox drumherum.
Du hast Namespaces und Cgroups drumherum.
Namespaces ist dafür da, den Prozess vorzugaukeln,
zum Beispiel so Sachen wie Hostname, der anders ist,
oder, was gibt es denn da sonst noch,
Loopback-Netzwerk-Device und glaub, solche Dinger.
Also das und du hast Cgroups für Ressourcen-Limitierung
und solche Geschichten.
Aber das zusammen ergibt quasi einen Linux-Container.
Unser Linux-Container-Support im Kernel,
das setzt sich ja zusammen aus Cgroups, Namespaces
und ich glaube, es gibt noch was Drittes, was dabei kommt.
Dementsprechend, egal, ob du so einen Container jetzt
mit Kubernetes startest, mit Docker startest,
mit Podman startest, mit LXC, LXD, wie auch immer startest,
unter der Haube ist das alles das Gleiche.
Das ist nämlich das, was im Linux-Kernel drinne ist.
Der Rest ist Frontend drumherum.
Und ein Prozess so gestartet auf der Kommandozeile
oder so ein Prozess gestartet als Container
ist kein Unterschied zu wirklich.
Da hast du ein bisschen, du hast minimale Sandbox drumherum.
Das kannst du aber nicht mit einer VM vergleichen.
Das siehst du allein schon daran.
In einer VM hast du ein vollwertiges Betriebssystem laufen,
wo du beispielsweise auch Kernel-Module nachladen kannst.
Ein Container benutzt den Host-Kernel.
Da kannst du nicht einfach Module nachladen.
Und deswegen taucht ein Docker-Prozess
auch in PSAugs ohne Probleme auf.
Na gut, jetzt in dem Fall nicht.
Aber habe ich hier irgendwas?
Ja, guck mal hier, was weiß ich.
PSAugs, läuft das überhaupt noch?
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich da drinnen gestartet habe.
Bin mir gar nicht sicher.
Ja, guck.
Also Docker-Prozesse und so tauchen hier ganz normal drinnen auf.
Da wird nichts virtualisiert.
Man kann es vielleicht virtualisieren.
Es ist eine minimale abstraktions...
Nein, nicht mal.
Es ist eine minimale Sandbox drumherum.
Aber einen Prozess starten, so, oder einen Prozess starten,
das ist ein Problem.
Das ist ein Problem.
Ein Prozess starten, so, oder ein Prozess starten im Container,
ist mehr oder weniger das Gleiche.
Du kannst einen Container abschießen mit Kill von deinem Terminal aus.
Das kannst du mit einer VM nicht machen.
Du kannst die komplette VM killen.
Das funktioniert.
Aber du kannst keinen Prozess in deiner VM killen,
weil dein Host von einem Prozess in deiner VM keine Ahnung hat.
Einen einzelnen Prozess in einem Docker-Container,
als Ruh da bamm kaputt machen, funktioniert?
Du hast das Spiel durch den Skript auf der Lutris-Page
und dann habe ich den Ubisoft-Connect Lutrisiert
und dann war es durch das, resultierte ein Verschleißverlust.
Ist es wegen irgendeiner Art Manjaro-Firewall-Nunzense?
Die Antwort war, dass die Multiplayer schon arbeiteten,
die Anno1800 mit einem Gold-Rating auf ProtonDB geholfen haben,
aber jetzt nicht.
Ist das zu sagen, dass es nie wieder funktioniert?
Wenn du ein Linux-Developer-Wizard bist,
kannst du es dir selbst machen.
Oder du musstest einfach nur warten,
und dann kannst du es dir selbst machen.
Aber alles, was auf einen externeren Nutzungsservice liegt,
das einzigartig von deinem Computer updateiert,
kann unerwartet gebrochen werden.
Und das sind heute viele Spiele.
Du musstest also immer darauf achten,
dass du vor allem die neuesten Kommentare lernst,
anstatt nur auf den Rating auf ProtonDB zu achten.
Ein weiteres Beispiel ist Minecraft-Dungeons.
Das funktioniert sehr gut,
aber es gibt noch einiges,
in dem du es durch Steam,
anstatt durch Microsoft direkt mit dem alten Launcher,
kannst du es dir selbst machen.
Aber für die meisten Leute,
ist es sicher zu spüren,
dass du es nur mit dem Windows-Store laden musstest.
Du wirst es nur mit dem Windows-Store
nicht so einfach simulieren können.
Ich konnte das mit meinen Kindern in einem Monat nicht spielen.
Das war das letzte Beispiel.
ProtonDB, wiederum Respekt für die Arbeit, die du machst.
Es kann dir viel Zeit sparen,
aber es kann dich nicht automatisch alle Probleme lösen.
Gold, für mich,
bedeutet, dass ein typischer Spieler es machen kann.
Das ist das, was ich vorhin auch witzte.
Das ist das gleiche Problem,
das ich früher mit WineHQ hatte.
Das ist der Vorgänger davon.
Da steht dann da,
läuft Silber.
Man kann es installieren.
Ja, super.
Für mich würde heißen,
Silber,
wenn man mal diese Stats nimmt,
bei Bronze lasse ich mir vielleicht gefallen,
wenn ich sage,
es lässt sich installieren.
Alles, was sich nicht installieren lässt
und nicht starten, ist rot.
Es lässt sich installieren,
es lässt sich starten,
aber es hat schwere Probleme
und permanente Crashes.
Da würde ich mir vielleicht noch gefallen lassen,
okay, wir sind auf einem guten Weg,
dem könnte man vielleicht Bronze ergeben.
Aber ab Silber muss es lauffähig sein,
komplett.
Wenn was Silber ist, würde ich erwarten,
es lässt sich installieren,
es lässt sich starten,
es lässt sich spielen,
aber es gibt vielleicht größere Grafik-Clitches
oder den einen oder anderen Crash.
Aber du kannst das Spiel im Prinzip spielen,
wenn du über Grafikfehler und fehlende Wände
ab und zu so mal hinweg sehen kannst.
Okay, das würde ich sagen ist Silber.
Gold,
oder Performance-Probleme oder so was, genau.
da sind wir übrigens gerade falsch.
Gold, würde ich sagen,
Gold ist, es installiert ohne Probleme,
es startet ohne Probleme
und ich kann das Spiel von Anfang bis Ende
ohne größere Probleme durchspielen.
Das wäre für mich Gold.
Ich lasse es mir gefallen,
wenn ein paar kleinere Probleme auftauchen,
was weiß ich.
Ab und zu gibt es mal
kurze Frame-Einbrüche beim Wechseln
vom Gebiet zum Beispiel
oder so was.
Oder im Options-Menü,
wenn ich dort ganz wilde Dinge einstelle
in ganz komischer Kombination,
dann kann das Game vielleicht doch
noch mal crashen oder so was.
Im Prinzip sollte Gold bedeuten
installierbar, startbar
und ohne Probleme von Anfang bis Ende
durchspielbar.
Platin bedeutet natürlich dann
native-like.
Es ist nicht native,
es ist nicht explizit dafür entwickelt,
aber Platin würde für mich bedeuten,
du kannst es als normaler Noob
installieren und benutzen wie native.
Ohne dass du irgendwas machen musst.
So würde ich das machen.
Ist es aber nicht.
Wie gesagt, Silber ist in vielen Fällen
es installiert und startet
und lässt sich gar nicht spielen.
Das ist halt fehl.
Lief das mal, ja?
Die China-Chinesen haben ja da
auch kein Interesse dran.
Das stimmt, du installierst das,
dann musst du erst mal hoffen, dass es funktioniert
und dann musst du erst mal zwei Stunden
vorm gucken, dazu nicht vielleicht noch
irgendwelche YNC-FG-Tweaks,
rüberkopierte DLLs von Windows
oder sonstige Hex brauchst
und dann kannst du spielen, wenn du Glück hast
zwischendrin kackts ab.
Stolz.
Java.
Ah, ist jetzt vorbei.
Nein.
Und das Jahr des Linux Desktop
wird es höchstens sein,
wenn die Leute mal anfangen
und WSL
und WSLG
zu verwenden.
Und wenn man das als Jahr des Linux Desktop
verkaufen möchte, dann
vielleicht dann, ja.
Das stimmt, Ok, viele kleine
Indie-Dinger, glaube ich, sind
viel problemloser
möglich, ja.
Nicht, dass ich es probiert habe, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Ich verstehe auch gar nicht, ganz ehrlich,
warum muss man überhaupt was
konverten? Gut, man kann das jetzt aus
irgendwelchen, sagen wir mal,
Glaubens- und Überzeugungssachen
machen, so nach dem Motto
ich möchte Microsoft in
keinster Art und Weise supporten,
ich denke, oder was weiß ich,
wenn Leute sagen, hey, Microsoft
liefert Malware mit aus, oder was auch immer.
Also, wenn man aus irgendwelchen
Gründen sagt, man
möchte Microsoft auf gar keinen Fall
supporten, dann, ja,
dann wird einem nicht viel übrig bleiben,
wenn man so einen Richard Stallman-Poster
irgendwie über dem Bett hängen hat, oder so.
Dann
bleibt da nichts anderes übrig, aber dann ist
man wahrscheinlich auch schon längst auf Linux
oder, sorry, GNU-Linux,
by the way, wer hat die
Copypaster am Start?
Ich wusste, dass das kommt.
Beste Copypaster
aller Zeiten.
Beste Copypaster aller Zeiten.
Genau.
Ja, ja, ob...
Interject...
Interjectet man alle, wunderbar,
Chat.
Jetzt habe ich den ganzen
Faden verloren, was ich sagen wollte.
Ja, dann ist man wahrscheinlich
schon umgestiegen oder hat das gemacht.
Wunderbar.
Aber, für alle anderen
finde ich,
die Frage muss ich eigentlich gar
nicht stellen, ob man das
umstellen soll.
Warum verwendet man nicht einfach
beides?
Warum verwendet man nicht Windows
für Sachen, die man nicht gut unter Linux
machen kann? Bei mir ist es in dem Fall
hier mein
YouTube-Zeug, ja, Thumbnail-Bearbeitung
damit, Videoschneiden
damit,
Steam, sonstiges Zeug
spielen, streamen,
alles mögliche, gut, schön
und gut, aber Sachen programmieren,
basteln und entwickeln unter Linux.
Man kann das doch parallel, man kann das doch
beides benutzen. Es muss dann
nicht entweder oder sein.
Einfach beides benutzen und das an der Stelle
was am einfachsten ist. Warum
sollte ich mir das Leben schwer machen?
Na gut, beides ist zu kompliziert
und umständlich für Otto Normal
User. Ja gut, Otto Normal
User wird das verwenden, was auf seinem Rechner
vorinstalliert ist. Der wird sich
garantiert auch nicht selbst Linux installieren.
Also wenn man Anwendungsgebiete hat,
die besser unter Linux funktionieren
und unter Windows und die parallel verwenden
will, warum nicht einfach beides verwenden?
Ich sehe da überhaupt nicht das Problem.
Die heutigen Rechner
sind fett genug, was CPU und
RAM angeht, um ohne Probleme
eine Linux VM laufen lassen zu können.
Ich meine, man muss es
nicht so übertreiben wie ich.
Man braucht dafür keine 32 GB
RAM.
Wenn du eine Kiste hast
mit 8 wird es vielleicht ein bisschen eng,
aber spätestens, wenn du mehr als 8 GB
RAM hast, ist überhaupt kein Problem
permanent eine Linux Kiste nebenbei laufen zu lassen.
Und ich benutze
ehrlich gesagt meine Linux VM
für das meiste
nebenbei. Und
für Sachen wie
YouTube Videos gucken, Videos
schneiden, Thumbnails machen,
Sachen spielen verwende ich halt Windows. Fertig.
Ganz einfach. Einfach
beides verwenden und gut ist.
Ja, genau so mache ich das.
Shortcuts
ist tatsächlich Standard.
Du drückst
Control-Windows-Taste und dann kannst du
mit den File-Tasten deine Desktops durchswitchen.
Desktops legst du hier drüber an.
Du kannst da auch noch mehr hinzufügen.
Will man halt jetzt nicht.
Aber wenn ich jetzt mehr Desktops hinzugefügt
hätte, würde ich hier meine ganzen
Desktops. Wir gucken mal, wie viele
Desktops gehen dann maximal. Hab ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Oh Gott, Windows Usability.
Lull. Guckt euch das mal an.
Die haben nicht damit gedacht, dass jemand so viele
Desktops hinzufügen will.
Ok, ich weiß nicht wo das Limit ist,
aber wahrscheinlich relativ hoch.
So und jetzt kann ich hier
Desktops durchschalten.
27 Desktops durchschalten.
Ja, ich habe einen zweiten
Desktop gemacht für die VM und
also ich mache es meistens so.
Hier auf dem ersten Desktop habe ich alles mögliche drauf,
was ich halt so unter Windows mache.
Auf dem zweiten Desktop habe ich immer die Linux-VM
und auf dem dritten Desktop habe ich manchmal
Video-Stells.
Also,
wenn wir Bastel-Livestreams
machen, zum Beispiel, habe ich hier die Kameras und
sowas. Aber in der Regel verwende ich plus zwei
Desktops. So.
Und jetzt
muss ich den Kram erstmal wieder zumachen.
Klick, klick, klick, klick.
Und wie ist das mit dem
Mouse-Catch und sowas?
Ach so. Ja, das mache ich schon ganz automatisch.
Das habe ich jetzt vergessen zu erwähnen.
Also, wenn du von Windows in VM rein
switcht, ist kein Problem.
Du siehst hier jetzt, jetzt ist noch nichts in der VM.
Da klickst du einfach rein und gut ist.
Du musst einmal reinklicken.
Also, wenn du rein switcht,
noch bist du hier in diesem Overlay von VM
her. Und dann
klickst du einfach rein
und gut ist.
Dann bist du hier in diesem Overlay von VM
her. Du musst einmal reinklicken.
So. Und wenn du zurück
switchen willst von der VM
nach Windows, dann drückst du
Ctrl-Alt, dann jumpt das aus
der VM und dann drückst du Ctrl-Alt
Windows und jumpst drüber.
Das hast du nach zwei Tagen instant
dir angewöhnt. Ctrl-Alt,
Ctrl-Windows links,
Ctrl-Windows rechts, reinklicken.
Bei mir ist es mittlerweile
so, ich drücke automatisch immer Ctrl-Alt
davor, weil ich mir immer nicht merken kann, auf welchem
Desktop ich bin. So.
Das ist eine Sache, die hast du nach
zwei Tagen drin.
Immer noch on. Ja, eigentlich
viel zu lang, ne?
Ja, mit mehreren
Monitoren geht auch. Du könntest auch die VM
auf den zweiten Monitor packen. Das würde auch funktionieren.
Du kannst
aus Stream Deck switchen.
Ich hab mal einen Makro programmiert
für die Maus zum Desktop switchen.
Ist auch relativ easy. Machst du in einer
Maus-Software, simulierst du halt
den Tastendruck.
Wobei du das wirklich über die Maus-Software
machen musst und nicht über irgendwelche Auto
Auto-Hotkeys oder sowas.
Weil Auto-Hotkey funktioniert in der VM
nicht. Aber Maus-Treiber-Software
funktioniert in der VM.
Weil es halt hardwaremäßig aussieht.
Ja, selbst schuld.
Was macht
Ctrl-Alt?
Ctrl-Alt sorgt dafür, wenn du in
VM-Ware drinne bist, dass...
Weil guck, die Maus ist jetzt ja
gecrapped von VM-Ware. Ich kann hier nicht raus.
Wenn ich jetzt alt...
Wenn ich jetzt... Und auch
Shortcuts, zum Beispiel Ctrl-C,
geht in die VM.
Guck, Ctrl... Ach so, Ctrl-C,
Ctrl-B und so. Das geht,
das geht, das geht in die VM.
So.
Und wenn ich jetzt
Ctrl-Alt drücke, dann
release das, diesen Crap
von der VM auf die Maus und die Tastatur.
Es gibt quasi Tastatur
und Maus frei.
Was du jetzt auch siehst, jetzt habe ich hier auch das Overlay
und sowas.
Startest du die VM manuell?
Ja, die starte ich manuell.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich
mein Rechner boote, was so
einmal am Tag vorkommt,
gehe ich halt einmal auf den zweiten
Desktop und starte die VM.
Nö. Ja, doch.
Doch, ich habe was im Autostart. Im Autostart habe ich
meine verschlüsselten
Festplatten.
Die USB-Festplatte,
die zweite SSD, die
die
ganzen Platten, die dran sind,
die werden automatisch entschlüsselt
beim Windows starten.
Das geht natürlich nur nachdem das
Main Windows gestartet ist, weil sonst ist ja
der Key nicht da.
Nee, Ruhezustand mag ich nicht.
Ach so.
Ruhezustand von der VM.
Ja, das benutze ich immer. Ich mache die VMs nie aus.
Ich mache die VMs immer Pause.
Ich mache immer Pause
in der VM.
Und dann hängt es manchmal, weil die VM
gerade acht Gigabyte RAM
frisst.
So, und wenn es wieder einschaltet, dann geht es an der kleinen
Stelle weiter.
Also die VM mache ich immer in Ruhezustand
die Windows-Geschichte nicht.
Es ist überhaupt nicht disconnected.
Erzähl mal keinen Scheiß hier.
Nö, kein TPM.
Kann man alles machen? Ja, brauche ich nicht.
Wie siehst du dann noch den Chat oder so,
wenn du in einem anderen Desktop bist?
Den Chat, den sehe ich, weil ich einen zweiten Monitor habe,
wo der Chat drauf ist.
Ich lese den Chat hier ja auch nicht
auf dem Monitor. Den habe ich
unten rechts eingeblendet im OBS, dass ihr den
seht und hier jetzt halt, dass man sieht,
über was ich gerade rede.
Nee, ich habe einen zweiten Monitor, nee, nee, nee.
Also in meinem Fall ist es noch
einfacher, ich habe einen zweiten Monitor und einen zweiten Rechner
dran, aber das würde auch so funktionieren.
Jaja, nee, das würde aber auch
glaube ich so funktionieren. Ich muss euch
ehrlich sagen, ich habe schon lange Windows
hier nicht mehr mit zwei Monitoren dran verwendet,
aber ich gehe ganz stark von aus,
dass du die Desktops binden kannst an
Monitor, wobei es ist Microsoft.
Es ist Microsoft.
Ich wäre mir da doch nicht so sicher.
Hat mich schon jemand an meiner Stimme erkannt?
Ja, gut, auf der Gamescom
ist kein Wunder gewesen.
Man sind ja Leute, die sich damit beschäftigen,
auch in echt.
Wie sieht deine Backup-Infrastruktur aus?
USB habe ich letztens
im Video ganz kurz einmal gezeigt.
Meine Backups
sind die simpelste Variante, wie es sein kann.
Eine 10TB
externe USB-Fastplatte.
Fertig. Mehr gibt es nicht.
Einmal nachts R-Synch drüber.
Fertig.
Das war es, ja.
Ich bin schon die ganze Zeit einmal überlegen
mit Backup.
Wird die danach ausgehängt?
Äh...
Gute Frage.
Nö.
Die geht inaktiv nach 10 Minuten oder so.
Die ist da die ganze Zeit dran.
Es sei denn, sie ist ausgeschaltet,
wie in diesem Fall vom Video.
Dann passiert halt nichts.
Was hat der Master Chief?
Ach, Master Chef, nicht Master Chief.
Das sind zwei unterschiedliche Dinger.
Hat jemand das Twitch-TV-Show-Meter mitbekommen?
Das war auch so richtig dummes Zeug.
Alle die Leute haben halt einfach auf Twitch zusammen
irgendwelche Fernsehsendungen geguckt.
Ganz ehrlich,
die Leute sind so blöde.
Es war doch von Anfang an klar,
dass es
Copyright-Probleme gibt,
wenn man hier einfach anfängt,
komplette Serien, die nicht dafür freigegeben sind,
zusammen auf Twitch zu gucken.
Das war doch so klar.
Und ich mein, nur,
weil es am Anfang nicht gleich jemand getroffen hat,
heißt es ja nicht, dass man sicher sein kann,
es passiert nichts.
Also,
zumal, zumal,
wenn ja gerade bei Amis mittlerweile
Watch-Party mit Amazon machen kann,
die supporten das ja mit manchen Sachen.
Es geht mir um niemand Speziellen.
Ich weiß nur, dass das viele gemacht haben.
Ja, die haben sie kurz gebunnt.
Es könnte aber auch sein, dass es wieder
so ein typischer Twitch-Bun ist und nach dem Motto,
wir bunnen jetzt mal jemand, dass wir guten Willen zeigen.
Keine Ahnung.
Was natürlich ein bisschen fragwürdig ist,
muss ich ehrlich, muss ich auch sagen,
dass Twitch sich da einfach nur zugeguckt hat.
Ich mein, gerade mit dem,
mit diesen ganzen DMCA-Geschichten,
die man hier auf Twitch zu sehen hat,
hat man einfach nur zugeguckt.
Ich mein, gerade mit dem,
mit diesen ganzen DMCA-Geschichten,
die wir in der Vergangenheit hatten,
wäre es doch durchaus sinnvoll gewesen,
dass Twitch mal von sich aus sagt,
Jungs, lass den Scheiß sein,
das gibt Probleme
und kostet euch im Zweifelsfall euren Channel.
Und hätte das Twitch mal gesagt,
das hätten auch viele nicht gemacht.
Ich hab keine Ahnung,
wer als erstes war.
Keine Ahnung, das TV-Show-Meta ging an mir vorbei.
Ich weiß nur, dass das ein Ding war.
Oder, oder...
Ja, nee, ist es nicht mehr.
Natürlich muss es Twitch interessieren.
Twitch verdient ja Geld.
Twitch hat ja auch nichts davon,
wenn ihre Content-Creator gebannt werden,
gestrikt, wenn der Channel weg ist.
Also, Twitch hat schon ein Interesse daran,
eigentlich, da denke ich mir zumindest,
so ein bisschen auf seine Content-Creator zu achten,
dass die keinen Scheiß bauen.
Gerade bei den Großen.
Und dass die Großen sind,
die es zuerst trifft bei sowas.
Und außerdem sollte man ja auch von ausgehen,
dass Twitch und ihre Creator
eine gewisse Beziehung zueinander haben.
Dass die Creator machen Content
und Twitch passt halt auch ein bisschen drum herum auf.
Hätte Twitch gesagt,
Jungs und Mädels, passt auf,
das gibt Probleme,
dann hätten das viele auch nicht gemacht.
Bin ich mir ziemlich sicher.
Klar kannst du erwarten, dass die Leute
für sich selbst denken, wobei...
Okay, das nehme ich zurück.
Ich glaube, du kannst nicht erwarten,
dass die Leute für sich selbst denken.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch zu Sachen,
die wir gucken können?
Leute, das ist 13.14 Uhr,
ich muss jetzt was furtern.
Vielleicht bin ich heute Abend nochmal am Start,
Leute, ich gehe jetzt erstmal was essen.
Pepo Fett.
Ich gucke mal, ob ich das hier anstehe.
Ja, das ist es.
Pepo Fett.
Ich gucke mal, ob ich noch schnell
irgendjemand hosten kann, der es verdient hat.
Irgendjemand Kleines, dem ich
followe.
Ich sehe gerade niemand.
Cyrus ist am Start, was macht er denn?
Mountain Plate.
Oh ne, das ist ja gar nicht meins.
Was gibt's zu essen?
Ist der wieder on?
Den können wir echt hosten.
Was macht der denn?
Äh...
Was?
Später Avatar
schauen nicht.
Oh no, Dread Action.
Big Brain Time.
Ja, den können wir hosten.
Raid, Raid.
Ich gehe jetzt aber gleich runter
essen, Leute.
Ich bin da nicht im Stream.
Und auf die Frage gehen, was es zu essen gibt.
Ich glaube, irgendwelche Reste.
Ich vermute mal Reis und
Schorizo. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das so ausspricht.
Schorizo.
So Spaß.
So spanische Wurst.
Node Red, ja.
Leute, wir sehen uns.
Bis denn.
See you.